this is Jocko podcast number 208 with
echo Charles and me Jocko willing
good evening echo good evening let me
have your attention at this point you
must complete a 12 mile tactical foot
march in three hours you must wear all
equipment properly you must have Kevlar
helmet on your head and you must carry
your m16 rifle at the ready position
this means that the rifle must be ready
for use against the enemy discuss
appropriate safety precautions and
candidates responsibilities for helping
injured candidates then say what are
your questions if anyone has questions
repeat the instructions but do not
elaborate on what you have read pause
five seconds and then say begin in those
right there are the instructions to be
given by the cadre two candidates for
the EEI be the expert infantry badge in
the US Army that's a qualification that
requires knowledge and a plethora of
different weapons including pistols
rifles machine guns grenades anti-tank
weapons it requires skill in combat
medical care skills and coordinating and
calling for supporting arms land
navigation chemical and biological
operations amongst other things and a
12-mile foot march that is one of the
evolutions that you are not allowed to
retest on you either make it or you
don't and that makes sense because the
foot March and I think that's really a
nice way of
saying it so what we used to call a
forced road march is a physical and
mental test of will and I talked about I
talked about the road march in podcast
38 of the patrol patrolling in teams
patrolling with my family and I started
off that podcast with a little reading
of infantry columns by Kipling boots and
I explained that marching or humping or
patrolling or rocking explained what it
meant to me how he impacted me and how
in many ways it can be a bit of a
metaphor for life and I'm not the only
one who feels that way and with me on
the program tonight is a former Special
Forces soldier who's also impacted by
the patrol by the hump by the rock and
who has made his new mission to spread
the power of the rock so here we go
Jason McCarthy welcome to program thanks
for having me Jocko thanks for coming on
man it's good to meet you
likewise likewise so let's just jump in
to figure out sort of how you ended up
how you ended up where'd it all start
where were you born
where are you raised born in Dayton Ohio
right so southern Ohio and but never
really lived there mom and dad were both
really young when they had me mom was
like how young mom was 18 and 5 days
dang right so how old was dad dad was 19
okay right and you know as you might
expect marriage didn't last super long
grandparents weren't super happy about
this but you know they they ended up
taking very vested interest in me
but my mom was was actually she was the
real athlete in the family she won
junior college nationals in tennis after
having me at Sinclair Community College
Wow right there and then got a full ride
to go play for the the Gators down in
Gainesville so we moved to Florida and
then just bounced her answer who's
raising you well obviously my mom and
she's so she's going to college winning
national level tournaments in tennis and
raising you yes and so she's a bit of a
trooper huh she's very much a trooper
very much and so you know I mean I some
of my earliest memories are going to to
her tennis practices in her tennis
matches and my grandparents flying down
and take care of me Walt no was she
raised like a tennis kid yeah sort of
him in an athlete uh-huh and just across
the board just across the board and then
she ended up being really good at tennis
she was number one and Ohio her whole
youth and so it just extended from there
when you're really good at something
just managed to have a kid so was she
nice yeah
what she managed yeah I mean managed to
is that like her senior year yes so she
ended up graduating early and then
almost went into hiding sort of at my
dad's house with my dad's parents who
were you know a little more okay with
the situation than my mom's parents it
was tough mm-hmm no doubt yeah no talk
can't even imagine this is what year
were you born 1979 yeah so it was like
society was still a lot more I'd say
hard to deal with from that perspective
of like a young mom in high school I
mean single moms
I mean it's that's tough and the older I
get the more respect I have for how
tough kids are and especially you know
especially a single mom with with a
young kid and still trying to live your
life and go to college and then get a
job and do those kinds of things so you
sir you have memories early on you're
like one year old and you're going to
tennis tournaments with your mom well I
was and all the other little
18 19 year old college girls are like
worried about their
hair and your mom's like hold on I gotta
feed my kid it's something like I was 2
or 3 and remember the tennis coach at
Florida he used to always pull my ear
his name was Andy Brandi and he would
pull my ear before the matches and you
say are you gonna behave today right and
so it was it inspired behavior that was
good from me yeah cuz like but once
again I'm picturing these girls playing
your mom and you know they're worried if
there's there's some distraction over on
the side is like a camera going off
meanwhile your mom's got the screaming
baby that's nuts man she had a lot on
her plate
yes she did and so then and so at what
point did she kind of give up tennis and
move into or did she like become a
tennis pro at a club or something like
that yeah so I mean I'm convinced that
without me she would have at least tried
to go pro and she was really good you
know and and she just she had me and
graduated and what 85 so I would have
been 6 years old when she graduated from
Florida and you can't go graduate from
Florida University University of Florida
Gators and so instead you know she ended
up getting remarried and did become a
teaching tennis professional and did
that for about 20 years so yeah we we
moved well we moved to Texas in
Tennessee and back to Texas and then
settled in in Jax beach Flor how old
were you settled in Jax beach florida we
moved there in 1992 then how old were
you so I was eighth grade okay
first year in school they're sort of how
I associate I remember the grades where
I was in which city and yeah but so you
did your full high school career in
Jacksonville I did and so you were born
and raised kind of with a tennis racket
in your hand
I assume tennis racket in a basketball
and tennis eventually won out but how I
got cut from the eighth grade basketball
team all right so it's weird cuz that's
the new kid and I move and I was I did
really well in basketball when I'd moved
from Texas and I just I moved to Florida
and it just didn't click for tryouts and
didn't know anybody and they're like
sorry and it was kind of a crushing blow
and this is not one of those things
where
you know the Michael Jordan's story
takes place and I and I doubled down on
my training and practice and became a
great basketball player I played pickup
pickup but I hate yeah I got quit Josh
like quitting is forever and I quit but
I still play tennis and that was you
know easier to make the team and stuff
so I did that and did that through
college
so you played tennis in college I did
one of my friends played tennis at the
Naval Academy and his sophomore year he
lost a match and he stood in the court
and through his five tennis racquets out
of the court into the woods and never
played tennis again quitting forever
right yeah
I've been using the teams he's a great
guy but it he just he'd never wanted to
pick up a tennis racket again and
independent obviously to play at the
Naval Academy have been a big focus in
his life for a frustrating sport it's a
frustrating sport I mean an init it it
teaches you to makes you very sensitive
to what you think are your needs to
write because you're alone and you're an
individual and you're out there and you
take everything so seriously and you
know one of the things that the military
culture would bring out is that you have
to be able to overcome the little stuff
you know someone someone clapping too
loud to courts over that can just ruin
your life if you're playing tennis and
that's you know like be quiet be quiet
it's it's ridiculous and you know you
you have to learn how to fight through
that kind of adversity yeah the other
thing about tennis like in jiu-jitsu if
you make generally if you make a little
mistake you can kind of recover from it
you can make it adaptations and what and
usually one mistake now look you can
make a mistake in jiu-jitsu and that's
it you can get our marker you can get
choked it happens but you can also make
a mistake and you can recover from it
and it's nothing it will have not a big
factor but you can you can hit a ball
into the net that's it you just lost
that point yeah the point but not the
not the game not to set not the match
you can I mean you can come back from
huge deficits in in tennis and it's it's
really like everything else it's it's
mental so so you played tennis in
college I did I went to M
in Atlanta and then were you thinking
that you could be some kind of a pro
tennis player absolutely not I was just
I mean so I love the the team element of
tennis I kind of stopped enjoying the
individual part of it it just it's a lot
of travel it's a lot of you know it's
just the the process of playing tennis
in my youth was I really enjoyed the
team part of it and so that continued
through college and I really enjoyed it
and with my team and in college I just I
wasn't good enough it just wasn't gonna
happen now I did consider hey maybe I'll
go down to South America or and like try
to play some tournaments or something
after college but I tore my rotator cuff
my senior year and couldn't you know so
when you're when you're trying to
measure yourself at that juncture in
life are you looking at hey I'm this
powerful or you're serving let's just
try and break it into something that a
normal non tennis player human can
understand let's say you're serve a good
serve is a hundred and twenty miles an
hour that's a big serviette okay or
let's say 100 miles an hour is like the
minimum to join a pro and you're serving
let's just say I'm not saying you in
particular let's say enough human
serving 90 and they're trying and
they're trying all these different
things and they just can't really make
it happen is that basically what happens
I mean at some point are you saying look
it doesn't matter how much I practice I
don't have the physical aptitude to be
top level yeah I mean you get into
really really thin air you know and and
just like in buds or in the training
that I went through there's there's
physical capabilities that will limit
certain people but there's also mental
stuff that will limit certain people and
mine were mostly physical I just wasn't
fast enough on the court I wasn't I mean
you get into really thin air where I
mean these guys that are great at tennis
and girls that are great at tennis I
mean they were kind of always really
great you know but I think that it's
it's important to to find something to
be a part of a team the
throughout your life and and to do more
of that and so for me it was really just
a vessel I mean I don't want to confuse
myself even with my mother my mother was
a great athlete and when it came to
tennis and you know I just I didn't get
the same degree my grandfather was in
played basketball growing up but you
know he was he was drafted to go play
for the for the Lakers but couldn't
afford the bus ticket from Colorado to
Californians so he went and got a job I
mean times were very different back then
and can you imagine that's crazy
and so when you go to college are you
would you go to college for studied
economics and what were you thinking
your future looked like yes so I was
thinking I didn't really know but I
thought I would do something in business
or consulting or I had these you know
these it's a really tough state to be in
when you're in your early 20s
and you're you're going to college or
you're trying to figure out your life
and you don't know where it's gonna go
those are hard years and you look at
them from an older vantage point and you
say you kind of had to go through that
and it doesn't make it any easier when
you're going through it though and so I
just I really didn't know I wanted to do
something special I wanted to do
something more and I just had no idea
what that would would mean and so you
know you just sort of say oh maybe I'll
go work at Goldman Sachs that's a great
place to work or I'll go work at
McKinsey and be a problem-solver or
something to that effect and he just
didn't I didn't know I didn't know and
so graduated 2001 May and still didn't
know but you know a few months after
that it was going to be a very different
world so did you get a job right after
college I did I went and travelled a
little bit around Central America for
like a month or two and that type of
stuff gets it gets kind of old you don't
really find yourself when you go far
away it just sort of amplifies what
you're already thinking and I needed to
do something I need
mission I needed purpose and I needed a
community and did you I mean obviously
your mom wasn't in the military your dad
your grandpa was there any military
roots that you had in your family so my
my grandfather was an artillery officer
in Korea never talked about it
everich right my uncle was a naval
aviator he was a class of 77 Annapolis
grad but never really saw him so it
wasn't part of my the decision-making
process of my life this is what I can go
do it was just it was a bridge too far
right I didn't understand what the
military did frankly I mean yeah defend
America but how what's what does that
mean for a life right I mean when I grew
up it was peacetime I mean it was aside
where'd you graduate high school 97
right so I mean this is not a time when
the military is front and center as it
is now and in fact if anything what was
the military's purpose at that time it
didn't have a ton of what Wars being
fought there I basically what I'm saying
is this I didn't get it it was naive but
I didn't get it and it seems like it was
just kind of outside your purview of the
world right I mean it wasn't on the news
every day you weren't seeing military
operations on the news every day like
you'd see now so just you're growing up
and it wasn't a thing that was really
part of your world look there was no
John F Kennedy at the time you know ask
not what your country can do for you ask
what you can do for your country that
wasn't part of the discussion in our
country and I think that's that's a
problem and that should always be a part
of the discussion and that just wasn't
the landscape where we are so or where
we were
so it took 9/11 to really bring that to
the forefront so wait a second South
America do you go solo down there who'd
you go and I went with a buddy
we just sort of backpacked quote quote
around
and you're thinking you're gonna see the
light and find your future you know I'm
gonna just find this magical adventure
like DiCaprio did in the beach or
whatever and it's gonna be life-changing
and whatever you know all who all who
wander are not lost yeah that's true but
some that wander are lost right and you
know part of it is you want to have an
adventure you don't know exactly how to
do it but you got to do something you
can't just sit around and do nothing so
did you come to any conclusions on your
backpack like he did I needed a mission
I need you I'll figure that out you guys
I was it was awesome but so boring like
I just I needed to be part of something
bigger than myself
you can't backpack around the world for
the rest of your life you just can't do
it it's it's it's easy to sort of
glamorize and you know but it's it gets
old
yeah too much freedom too much freedom
is right for yours there's a lot of time
in the day and and we we oftentimes
think oh man this happened so fast and
did you know today's gone tomorrow's
gone I don't have time for anything you
have a lot of time it's just how you
prioritize it so you so did when you
came back from that trip that you
actually get a job somewhere I did I
know where was that so I was working at
a call center in Daytona Beach and was
doing kind of research around car
dealerships and who we could call and
target for stuff like you're sensing my
enthusiasm at the same time I was
grateful to have a job huh
and I needed a job and so that so were
you hammering the phone lines I was so
you started off as an ugh okay call
these call these numbers ask these
people what kind of interior they'd like
in their vehicles or whatever it was
actually direct to the dealerships so I
was trying to figure out you know I can
barely remember uh-huh trying to get
more dealers onto this marketing
campaign that the company was running
sure and no part of you was thinking
Here I am I found it I had very much not
arrived
then you had that job is that when you
had that job is when September 11th
happened correct and and what was your
what was your thought pattern once
September once you saw the towers get
hit so if you remember JFK jr. had died
in a Cessna and Cessna plane I think it
was a Cessna that he you know he was
piloting and it went down and like off
the coast of Long Island something like
that right and and so you know that was
kind of the initial reaction and I think
there was just general confusion and I
woke up I was getting ready to go to
work with my you know button-down and my
khakis and stuff right eating my cereal
and I had the news on and so I remember
watching stuff go down and it just there
was just general confusion and so I was
confused as well like oh this is an
accident and then you just sort of watch
it escalate and it was obviously very
clear that it wasn't an accident yeah
for me first plane hits which I think I
heard on the radio
so even when I hear the plane hit there
you know one of the Twin Towers I'm like
Oh Cessna you know pilot doesn't know
what he's doing was probably foggy
whatever he's taking a joy rod that
that's horrible and then then I saw the
images like somewhere you know saw the
images on TV or something and of the
first building of the first tower
getting hit and I thought oh wow how
does that happen as soon as I saw the
second you see that plane come in yeah
as soon as I saw the second one hit I
was like oh that was it that was this is
pre-planned terrorist attack ghost bumps
thinking about how much rage I felt at
that moment in time so how long did it
take you to say to yourself you're gonna
go in the military right so the initial
reaction was I got it this is this is my
mission I got to figure out how to serve
America something greater than myself
the the more practical side was joining
the military in a time of war was scary
there was fear human fear that was
running through my veins about this is
that's a real decision
and the other part of it was you know
the first death was Mike's pan so Mike's
pan was in work for the CIA and you know
before that was a Marine but they sort
of glossed over that in the telling of
it you know he was a he was work for the
CIA and he was in Afghanistan one of the
first in and so I took a lot of
inspiration from that and sent my packet
in to the CIA and a couple other of the
alphabet soup agencies that were
generally speaking in the DC area and
that's a really long process so you know
went through that entire process and met
some good people along the way met some
of the the hiring folks at the agency
and I kept asking about I didn't know
anything okay I heard about you know SOG
and like the it's called ground branch
right that's the paramilitary branch of
the CIA that's where I wanted to be and
so I didn't know how to get there and
finally you know you make it through
round after round after round of
interviews with the agency and they get
more sort of specific and you have
one-on-one time with interviewers and
you're encouraged to ask questions which
you should I'm like hey so how do I get
to do that kind of stuff like the
mission that Mike Spann got how do I do
that and there was this guy and we were
in you know some office space very as
you might expect sterile looking office
space in Northern Virginia and this guy
sitting at a desk not not too dissimilar
to how we're sitting right now looked
right at me he's like look we don't
train our guys in the military we take
from the Special Operations branches and
then they come and work for us and I had
this moment in my head I'm like damn man
why didn't you tell me this like a year
ago right and and so that's when it
clicked for me and so now I'm resetting
the clock though because I start going
through military application processes
at that time and that's you know mm late
2002 and you know there's this
perception out there was this perception
I think there's a lot of us who are
working really hard to dispel it that
you either go to war you go to jail the
military has a last option resort of you
can't get a job somewhere else so you
should go join the military and that's
just patently false and so you know it
was one of those things where a lot of
people wanted to join the military a lot
of people with really really stellar
resumes in the aftermath of 9/11 we had
a nation of people who said send me I
want to go to war to fight for my
country now that's great for the country
it's hard if you want to go join the
military so you know I just graduated
from college of course I'm gonna become
an officer and of course I don't tell
anyone in my family anything that's
going on right so my hair is grown out I
was working out a lot to sort of do the
kind of physical training or physical
fitness that I thought I needed to do in
order to join the military and be of
some value to someone in some
godforsaken place downrange and so they
thought I was just going off the deep
end you know I just graduated from this
expensive college I sort of didn't
really have direction or purpose I
wasn't working for the in the call
center this ya know so I actually moved
up to be closer to DC I wanted to be
closer to where I thought the action was
in buy action I meant where service was
happening and to me that was that was
New York and DC and so I moved up to DC
I had some family up there I I worked as
an analyst at a bank then right which is
a great way to work a hundred hours a
week by Wednesday right and sleep on the
floor you know for a couple hours before
your your boss is all 18 of them come in
the next morning with more stuff for you
to do and so I was up in DC for for that
period because the interview processes
were long and drawn-out and I didn't
know where I wanted to go but all those
places were in DC so like going through
those processes there was a little bit
easier and also the the military process
so my first place that I applied was to
become a Marine Corps officer and that
just I mean kept going through hey
you've been selected to go to
basic no officer candidate Sultana
school in the price right and that just
they kept not happening and eventually
it's like man the wars are just passing
me by like it's time so dude do what you
got to do but you need to do it now or
you will regret this for the rest of
your life so I went down and then I
started talking to I went and was gonna
go to the Navy recruiting center which I
did and asked about becoming an officer
in the Navy and how do I become a seal I
think well that takes forever right and
Mike well I don't have forever because I
want to go fight a war right so what
next door to the to the army recruiter
and he said the same thing right he's
like this takes forever right if you
want to go be in Special Forces that's
you you can do that when you're a
captain promotable or oh three
promotable or sorry Oh two promotable
about to be a captain I think was was
the the timeframe on that so that's
years away
now the idea of going and joining an
infantry unit or something it didn't
appeal to me I wanted to be and you have
these grandiose notions of what you're
capable of and I wanted to be the guy in
the mountains hunting bin Laden that's
what I wanted to do with my life and and
so the guy sends this you know these
recruiters they they know and they've
got something he's like well we've got
this special program right you can go
straight off the street and join Special
Forces
it's an enlistment I'm like ooh that
kind of sounded like a bad word to me in
the list right I mean college degree you
have all these senses of what you're
entitled to or what you should be doing
with your life and part of those are
pressures that you're felt from outside
forces and there's no doubt expectations
that family and loved ones they have for
what your life should be you know the
perfect life like Edward Norton and
Fight Club right assigning value to the
furniture in your house and what what
apartment you have and all these things
that really don't matter but you you
think about what you should do in life
in order to be happy and enlisting to go
be a ground pounder in the army was was
a little bit removed
from what I thought my direction should
be and yet that that was my choice it
was do this or sit around and wait
forever until they call and say okay now
you're you're validated and can go to
become an officer and man I didn't know
anything about this process I didn't
have anybody that I talked to about what
people did in these job no any SF guys
at all no and OD Marine Corps officers
no no and so it's like what you see so
the irony is that my next-door neighbor
that I lived next to in in Florida
growing up for a you know since 92
was an officer a Special Forces officer
in the army and it took until my mom
found out because I told her that I
didn't listed which just to jump to the
the the end a little bit here I ended up
signing a five-year contract enlisting
into the Army where they guarantee that
you can go to the schools they of course
don't guarantee that you'll pass and it
was only 18 X 18 X ray
so X ray just basically means that 18
series is the MOS and the X ray is the
designator for we don't know what your
job specifically within the within
Special Forces will be if you pass it
will assign it to you later
this is one of those questions I get
asked all the time by people which is
you know should I go officer should I go
enlisted you know this is just really
common for people to ask and you know I
was really lucky because I wouldn't
change us I enlisted and I wouldn't
change anything about my career my
career was ridiculously awesome and
super lucky and people asked me that
question all the time um it's really
hard to get a seal officer billet like
as a that as you joined the Navy it's I
think they I think there's about thirty
a year and there's thousands of people
that apply for it like the Naval Academy
takes fifteen I think it's 15 from the
Naval Academy and then 15 from ROTC and
OCS combined
so this is a tiny number and so I always
tell people look you can apply for that
but if you want to be a seal you do you
may end up just having to enlist and at
the same token is I'm so glad I didn't
want to go to college like I wanted to
the same as you I mean there was no war
going on but I wasn't smart enough to
figure that out I thought that there was
I thought that there were seals all over
the globe conducting covert operations
and I was gonna go get some of that
exactly but you know so I was like ready
to enlist and I wouldn't do it any other
way and I would I'd ended up going to
college when I was like 28 years old and
by then I was like okay I can I can sit
in the classroom now where now when I
was 18 19 20 I don't want to sit in a
classroom I wanted a machine gun you
know like a normal kid so yeah so I
think for people that are on that fence
for and anybody that knows me or it
listens to me at all I mean all day long
I'll tell you that being a being a
infantry soldier being an infantry
marine I mean those are being a machine
gunner in the Marine Corps I mean any of
those jobs are awesome and they'll lead
to real leadership enlisted leadership
positions and and it's a great
experience and a great jobs and I
wouldn't have it any other way I mean
and then on the officer side is like
well you know you're gonna if you go in
as an officer you're gonna obviously be
put in charge earlier you'll end up with
more leadership situations sooner so
there's there's benefits to it
but at the end of the day I think what
happened to you is what happens to a lot
of people it's like the the path becomes
clear not because of what you want but
because of the way the world works
and so when you know figure out what
your path that path should become clear
at some point and then you say okay cool
that looks like my path I'm gonna go and
one thing I will say is in the SEAL
Teams for sure I'm pretty sure it's this
way in the in the Army and the Marine
Corps if you're a good enlisted human
and you make an effort to become an
officer it's easier to become an officer
when you're an enlisted person than it
is to do it coming from straight out I
don't know
that's a hundred percent true in the
army in the Marine Corps but in the SEAL
Teams it's absolutely true it's you know
you you will have an easier time getting
selected if you are already in the SEAL
Teams for six years and now you want to
become an officer it's it's a little
easier but you can't count on it because
the program that I did they took fifty
people to become officers out of a whole
Navy so out of two hundred and fifty
thousand people in the Navy they took 50
that's not those aren't great odds but I
don't know I think the path I think what
happened to you is what happens to a lot
of people and you got to say okay the my
path has been revealed by circumstances
and I'm gonna go for it yeah you got to
do something I mean there's lots of
other alternatives you can do nothing
and you can regret it and that's a
really that's the worst path of all yeah
well that's another good point that you
bring up then this is something else
that people ask me you know oh should I
do this now or I got a good job offer
but I really want to be in the military
or I want to go to college but I
whatever they have a million I don't
want to call them excuses they have a
million legitimate what they believe to
be reasons on why they should postpone
or possibly not even go into the
military and from my perspective all
these other opportunities you have in
life will be there for a long time but
the military will not be yeah that's a
very true sir I mean I've yet to meet
the person who served in the military
that regretted it Oh everybody says I
learned so much and what you really
learn is a perspective on life and I
don't care if you're an officer or
you're an enlisted or whatever you learn
about teamwork and camaraderie not as
posters on a words on a poster in a
bathroom but as just what it feels like
and and that becomes your Northern Star
in life you want to chase that for the
rest of your life I want to be a part of
a team I want to feel that reward of
service to a higher purpose than just
myself I want to help other people and
when you connect those dots you just you
need to go do it now I really I caution
people against thinking oh well I'm
gonna enlist so that I can become an
officer it's it's very rare and so
you sort of say it's not about the
actual mechanics it's about service and
you you get to pick your path and you
need to pick your path wisely and you
need to do it when you're young when
you're 20 here's what nobody tells you
you graduate from college or you're 20
years old or whatever your your basic
value in the universe is nothing you're
just you don't have wisdom or
perspective you don't know yourself and
that's the biggest part of this you you
haven't been through enough adversity at
a mature enough age even if you've got a
horrific childhood you're not in a
mature enough age to know yourself well
enough as you get older and so what the
military does is it forces you through
adversity to learn more about yourself
to how you'll respond to these kinds of
challenges in life and in life's a
really hard place for for all of us and
you don't get good at doing hard things
by only doing easy things so take this
job offer and this cush whatever that
you got and wad it up and throw it away
and find some cause that you really
believe in to serve and go go do that
and see what path that leads you to
because for me it's it's got nothing to
do at this point about oh well you know
the specifics of well a career or
however many years in the army and it's
got everything to do about the way of
life that I want to lead that I want
others to lead with me which is based
upon the time that I spent in Special
Forces you talked about a five-year
enlistment which when I joined the Navy
I've signed a six-year contract god
bless you your recruiter got you is you
got some high five boys on that yeah
this did the program that I did was
called the dive ferrer program and it
was a six year enlistment that same
thing it gave you an opportunity to do
the screening test to go to buds so this
is just completely ridiculous well
I remember thinking it seemed like a lot
of people just couldn't especially
people like you're saying that were my
age whatever 18 19 20 years old for them
for out for them and a little bit of me
was like six years seem like this
eternal length of time and the reality
is man six years is a joke
I mean six years of my 20-year career
went by you know I can barely even
remember six years so that's another
thing that people got to overcome they
got to overcome the fact that this seems
like a huge chunk of your life but but
the value that you're gonna get out of
it is infinitely worth way more than for
the rest of your life your life you what
else where else are you gonna find this
in your 20s yeah well you're not you're
not and it doesn't just have to be the
military there are a lot of other
organizations that you know you can
serve that are American needs you can go
be a teacher you can go there's lots of
things that you can do but ultimately
you need to find something with a
mission and purpose that you really
believe in and just pour your heart into
it work really really hard learn what
that feels like yeah and I think you
make a good point of it working working
really hard at something well working
really hard at being a soldier if that's
what you are passionate about is a lot
easier than working really hard in a
call center when you when you don't like
it or working really hard as an analyst
when it's like it's not what you want to
do and you don't see any greater purpose
behind it I mean you give me all day
long to teach people about leadership
which is what I do right now I do that
and I can't even stop doing it I mean
it's like I I work with a company and
I'm I'm so engaged with them it's like
awesome
but then you if you were to remove me
from that and put me into a you know
staring at spreadsheets and firfer a
bank it would be hard for me to you know
really find the passion and doing that
and and people are built differently as
well some people are you know some
people love the idea of going straight
to college at 18 and working really hard
at college and you know doing really
well and they could do that and that was
me as well I was I was doing I was
working with a company that made candy
candy good candy um not really like what
you think of when you think of good
candy more like just sort of the normal
when you when you go to a restaurant and
you leave and they have like mints I see
and you grab a handful of mints or
whatever they make that kind of candy so
this isn't like some gourmet candy that
they put on a pedestal and talk about no
it's not that
but anyways I'm I'm some speaking this
company I'm I'm with them I'm working
with them and they were talking about
this candy and all their different
variants of candy and what they're going
to do strategically and where they
needed to improve in market share
man they were into it they were into it
and so uh that that's they found
something and they were into it I was
like okay I was like this is awesome I'm
glad that these folks are totally into
this and so I guess to your point if you
are into you know if you're into
economics and you go to a bank and
that's what you're into and you love
trying to figure out trends and you hey
that's awesome
and and and you should proceed down that
path but if you're not into it then
maybe you should look for a different
path so I'll tell one more story about
this because it this is important I
think I can I started to understand so
I'm in the Navy I'm in the SEAL Teams
I'm on a ship we're out in the middle of
the ocean it's pitch black there's
massive waves it's raining and we're
getting ready to launch our little
zodiac boats you know and you're just
you're just launching into death I mean
it without not really you're launching
into just complete darkness right and
there's huge waves and there and it's on
a ship that has a well deck so the the
ramp is gonna go down on this thing and
we're just gonna have our boats there
and just jump into the ocean and there's
a there's a Navy guy a bosun's mate
which means he's like a deck hand guy
but he runs all the all the launching of
you know ships or launching of the
little boats and bringing boats back on
you know he runs all that stuff it's
important job in the Navy a bosun's mate
so as the the ramps going down the rains
pouring in the waves are
crashing and this guy looks at me and he
says and you know it's a hard job being
in bosun's mate because you're doing all
this kind of work of you know loading
vehicles unloading vehicles loading
bones unloading votes you're in charge
of making sure that the equipment is
maintained I mean it's like a hard job
anyways the boats everything smashing
and crashing in water and the guy looks
at me and he goes man I'm glad I don't
have your job and I looked back at him
and I said well you know what I'm glad I
don't have your job so let's make a deal
you do your job and I'll do mine and and
it was totally it was awesome it made
sense and the guy kind of laughed and we
smiled and then I launched out in the
middle of the ocean to go out and spend
you know four hours in a transit to get
to the beach to swim across the beach to
get onto the beach to do a three-day
reconnaissance freezing cold hey that's
what we do and that guy was gonna you
know be on that ship but that's another
thing that just uh I was in a perfect
place I love doing what I was doing and
he was in a perfect place cuz he loved
doing it you know he was part of
something that was big and part of
something I was bigger than himself you
know being in the Navy it was cool but
you got to find if you can find
something that you really liked doing
I just don't hate your life yes I mean
do not hate your life yeah we do not
recommend hating your life never change
if something goes on for too long and
you do not like waking up in the morning
then you've got to change something yes
and just to make sure because I'll get
asked this about a million times and
I've been asked it that doesn't mean you
walk into work tomorrow and throw your
computer at your supervisor
and tell them I'm going to do something
I love and then you're homeless no don't
do that what you do is you figure out an
exit strategy you come up with a plan
you actually think about it you take a
year to save money you figure out what
you're gonna do that's what you do two
jobs one paycheck sometimes the second
job is moonlighting is a passion a hobby
you try to turn that into reality work
really hard yeah there's not shortcuts
in this it's not hey let me let me fire
up a brand new Instagram account and
that's my new passion in life and I'm
gonna be
millionaire it's ridiculous right find
something that you really love to do and
two jobs one paycheck that's the deal
yeah or four jobs one pager or more sure
ten jobs one do figure it out in and by
the way traveling the world in hopes of
finding yourself is not a good plan
that's my general that's my general
experience yeah it's interesting you
actually found yourself while you're
sitting in a being an analyst or sitting
there on a call center you're like okay
this much I know I don't want to do this
yeah I mean I kind of knew I didn't want
to do that I just think there's a lot of
people out there that that want
especially in America where there's so
much opportunity we can do so many
things with our lives here there's just
so much freedom we don't even realize
and yet we feel enslaved to other
people's expectations and so we start
falling into that trap of well I got to
go do this and I got to earn this much
and I got to chase that sure did your
family meaning your mom your
grandparents your friends did they have
enough understanding of the military to
realize that when they disappointed when
you enlisted when they like oh no you're
officer material song they were
absolutely what my mom cried in the
kitchen she would have cried if she
would have cried if I wanted if I told
her I was becoming an officer either as
well I mean it was just one of those
things where it was a time of war and
that's hard for moms and God bless moms
I think they have the hardest job on the
planet and and so you know that was just
a really difficult time you know we had
it was October of 2003 that I that I
enlisted and you know the war in Iraq
had kicked off I felt like I'd missed it
you know you see them toppling the
statue of Saddam and I felt like I
missed it and you know yeah so I came
back from the recruiting station and I
told my mom in the kitchen and my
brother was sitting on them my brother's
younger and he was sitting on the
counter and I'd missed some calls and
some stuff and my mom was upset with me
and generally my mom just didn't know
what I was
with my life either right cuz she had
expectations that I was gonna do
something important with my life and I
wasn't doing that and I told her that I
didn't enlisted to go join Special
Forces and she just lost it and then
there were this sort of how long was it
between your enlistment when you left
for boot camp like three weeks so really
so maybe I wanna sit around October
first and I left 21 28th of October
pretty quick turn turned to her
yeah okay so mom's soul is crushed yeah
and then there's the aftermath with the
grandparents and my just the the family
so as we talked about earlier my mom was
really young when she had me and so a
lot of the rest of my family took a very
vested interest in me and I'm the person
that I am no such thing as a self-made
man and I'm a product of the time and
effort that they spent to help raise me
and including my dad I visited spent
tons of time with my dad in Ohio in the
summer and his parents and I just had a
lot of people in my life and there was
just a lot of questioning about this
decision was there anyone that said read
on good call my dad was actually almost
relieved he just said okay that sounds
about right yeah and but you know
everyone worries
you have to just accept that and so
selfishness is something that gets
thrown around as a very negative thing
and you know part of what you have to do
to make yourself happy is you have to be
selfish you have to say and call it
whatever you want but this makes me
happy I need to do this regardless of
the consequences and it's not just a
soldier that goes to war the family is
very much a part of that experience and
I completely shut them out throughout
this entire process and then just
dropped a bomb on him and said I'm
leaving in a month but I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go to boot camp and then I'm going
to war and you know there was a part of
me that really felt like that I knew I
needed to do it but it's it's a scary
thing I mean it's
a lot less scary to me now I mean the
idea of hey you've got to go back on the
next smoke and bird to Afghanistan or
Iraq I mean it's still something if
you're not scared at least a little bit
if you don't get an adrenaline rush
if someone's shooting at you there's a
problem you know like if you're not
mortally aware of what's going on
there's probably something not quite
right and and yet at that time it was
just so unknown I mean I I pretty much
resigned myself to the fact that I was
gonna die and I'm sure my mom did
alright so you show up at boot camp how
many hours or days was it into boot camp
that you said to yourself oh man it's
good I could not believe how hard boot
camp was
I mean how miserable it was it was and I
was a little older so I was 24 mm-hmm
and I like had a little bit more
perspective maybe than some of the the
guys were 17 and 18 which maybe that
wasn't a good thing I loved the fact
that I was really young going throughout
cuz you're just too dumb to figure I
mean I just I would look I would not
want to go through wheat when I was 24
years old I wouldn't have wanted to go
through boot camp I mean I would have
done it of course but it would have
sucked even more because you understand
the world a little bit better you you've
had some kind of a taste of freedom and
I mean I just was like hey okay you want
me to do this I'm gonna do it it was
like I was the perfect recruit really
always because I was just young and dumb
so I sucked at some yeah the biggest
thing I suffered from was just
overthinking stuff because I would sit
and why are they doing this that's the
worst thing that I can ask yourself yeah
why it doesn't matter yeah just do it
you have to learn how to just do yeah
and so do this is one of those things
that you need to learn in your 20s so
the what will make a huge impact is who
is telling you what to do because if you
align yourself with something that you
don't believe in with a person you don't
really
fact and they're telling you what to do
you're gonna adapt your life to their
way at that time and the the military
it's it's got a very powerful way of
creating very strong people wherever you
started you will end up stronger for
your time in the military and that all
begins with this basic common experience
of basic training and I just I couldn't
believe how how hard it was and how just
it was completely void of all social
norms and etiquettes and all of those
things I mean nothing was off-limits
in terms of their ability to denigrate
you for any reason whatsoever in navy
boot camp you are in open bay barracks
obviously and then the toilets are just
on the wall there's twenty toilets in a
row like you're gonna sit down on the
toilet and they're gonna be looking at
19 other people that are also said
there's no privacy whatsoever zero it's
all gone it's just zero and then the
other thing is because this is people
always you know they listen to podcast
and they hey I just didn't listen to
Marine Corps here just to listen the
army they'll send me that message and
I'm like okay 72 hours into boot camp
you're gonna hate me like just give it
another few more weeks because the thing
that we're not used to even as a 18 year
old is you're not used to your freedom
being completely gone completely there's
zero freedom when you get to boot camp
none zero you're gonna be doing what
someone else tells you do you have no
freedom to do anything you can't even go
to the bathroom when you want to go to
the bathroom you throw sergeant can I go
use the loosely you have units no
freedom whatsoever and that is as you
said very important lesson to learn on
life you learn to appreciate your
freedom and you also learn to deal with
the fact that hey just because some I
can't control this aspect of my life
doesn't mean I can't control other
aspects of my life and that's an
important thing to figure out as a young
person and you kind of learn to play the
game too right like
there's no way around this this drill
instructor this instructor is gonna do
this and the only possible thing I can
do I mean other than quitting is just to
shut up and just do what you're supposed
to do it's like okay cool
that's no options is a great option yeah
do it or do it or quit and you can't
quit boot camp you can quit buds or
Special Forces qualification course you
can't quit you're you literally go AWOL
then they go find you and one guy went
AWOL and they found him at the gas
station you know off base or whatever
trying to get someone to buy him some
coffee or something whatever and they
brought him back and you know then he
was back into it except he was a guy
with a bull's-eye on him because he's
the guy that went AWOL and they dragged
him back and it's it's I can't stress
enough what you just said you have zero
privacy and and this is a culture shock
for a lot of people because this is the
whole everything that we do our system
is based around a culture of I right at
its basic level now you have your iPhone
you have your individually wrapped
everything you have you know mimimi
right and that's gonna make you happy or
that's you know you everything is is
just centered around the individual and
the the army just doesn't prescribe to
that privacy I mean there's all these
privacy debates now social media and
your data and all of the privacy as if
that's just some right that you have and
that's fine there's there's some nuance
to that well let me just tell you 0% of
that exists in the military zero like
you said I mean there's just a lot of
naked dudes you know it open latrines
and and it's just that's what it is
and you learn that that's kind of a
primordial way to exist and you are much
more in touch with how our species
evolved over our entire evolution of
Homo sapiens when you join the military
and you just become in tune with that
yeah and I think the most important
message that gets relayed into your
brain whether you're conscious of it or
not
is crystal-clear and that is this team
in this organization is more important
than you are and your little wants and
needs and desires and your personality
doesn't matter when it's compared to the
needs of this team and this group and
this mission and that's important
another very important thing to learn as
a young person you're not at the center
of the universe period the end and so
now as that evolved for me one of one of
the most important lessons and this is
where you have to spend a lifetime
mastering it is to understand that to be
a great teammate first you have to be a
great individual and then you have to
submit to the team because anybody on
your SEAL Teams or my special forces
teams there these are people that can do
anything with their lives they if they
commit themselves they will do it and so
you have to become a master of your
trade a true professional and in that
that requires the discipline that you
have as an individual when nobody's
looking over your shoulder to just
continually refine and sharpen sharpen
the the blade right your own and then
though you have to realize that it's not
about you it's it's a it's a balancing
act for an entire lifetime and the more
that the more that you do both of those
in concert the more rewarding life will
be yeah and really the thing that drives
you to be as good as you can is because
you know your teammates are gonna be
relying on you and if you can't deliver
that's like the worst thing in the world
me being in the SEAL Teams like the
worst thing in the world for someone and
the teams for a good seal is like oh my
teammates were counting on me and I
couldn't deliver for him that's the
that's the lowest of the low hey look
somebody looks at me and says oh
chuckles not that fast or jhaqo couldn't
do enough pull-ups or whatever it's like
oh yeah that's on me no big deal but
when they needed me to climb that ladder
they needed me to finish that road March
or move to that position and I couldn't
do it
that's that's what always always drives
like a good team guy to be better as
like they don't want to let their
friends down period it's the ultimate
motivation yeah like to be a part of
that community and in the community
sharpens itself I mean you get guys and
competition competition breeds
excellence there for sure and so you've
got this world where as iron sharpens
iron so a friend sharpens a friend and
that is just everyday on the team
everything's a competition everything is
a competition so when you get done with
boot camp and then what you go to AIT
yeah for me I they kind of were lumped
in together cuz you know it was infantry
hunk boot camp and infantry AIT whatever
it was that it was just the same entire
crew at the same place in Fort Benning
over the winter in Georgia which was
just I mean it's it's horrible it's
really really cold and they just they
they put you in formation at Oh dark
thirty four whatever it stand there just
stand there and shiver I mean it is just
horrific the army the army beats the the
Navy at that as far as just formations
and just standing there because I'm the
only thing only real I guess the only
real army school I ever did that's like
sort of a basic army school so gone with
the Airborne School at Fort Benning
Georgia and like hey we're gonna get a
formation and we're gonna stand out here
until when until we're done standing out
here standing at a position of attention
that's another thing you like learn to
deal with the fact that you're not
always gonna be in control of what's
happening and how you gonna deal with it
you're gonna suck it up and stand there
guess what
stand there suffering silence this is
where all of these phrases come from
right you've got you've got so much
creativity because from these guys
standing in this formation with all this
available time to sit and think about
how miserable their life is right and
then you say how do you come up with
something sort of cute oh suffering
silence you know just stuff like that
and yeah there's a lot of lying a lot of
maybes like the more horrible
things that happen to you the more proud
you are and the more you relish in those
old days and that's where pride comes
from you know pride comes from like oh
we did really hard things and they
sucked and we're proud of them
yes and so the other parties this is how
you become a better leader it's how you
become more confident it's it's
incremental you don't just wake up one
day and all of a sudden you're Abraham
Lincoln right it doesn't work that way
you can't just sit and read books all
day you have to actually take books and
apply them to harder situations
incrementally and then what the military
taught me that teaches all of us is what
you're capable of doing and what you're
capable of enduring and it pushes your
body and it pushes your mind in
miserable horrific ways and you gain
confidence from that and you just you
climb one rung higher on the ladder and
then when life gets really really hard
then you can draw upon what you learned
throughout that process of the last rung
that you climbed the people I got asked
that recently you know people are always
looking for kind of the sound a good
sound bite a good
clickbait title for an article but you
know someone asked me something along
the lines of select what was the moment
that all this leadership stuff came like
he came clear to you and I was like
there wasn't one moment you know I
learned this stuff one mistake over a
little mistake over a big mistake over a
little mistake over years and years and
years and years and going okay and even
now I'll make a mistake tomorrow I'll do
something dumb this afternoon and learn
something else and that's your right
that is what the military does and it is
important that when you realize
something as stupid as hey you're gonna
stand in formation until it stops and
that could be two hours three hours you
don't even know how long it's going to
be and guess what when you get done with
that ok cool now we're done with that
and now the next thing you face you go
on you know what I I can get through
this I can get through this I can keep
my mouth shut
or I can drive forward or I can stand
here or I can stay in the push-up
position or I can
they awake on this patrol or I can sit
here and freeze in this cold weather
lay up position in the mountains I can
get through this and it won't make a
difference when I'm done so let's let's
just buckle in and get it done so the
evolution of that for for me was whoever
the early phases of the dispatch force
qualification course the cadre lined us
all up and not just for formation but he
goes all right here's the task at hand
you're gonna lunge around this building
until I get tired and like so you know
at that point standing in formation
didn't sound so bad
you know lunge around the building until
I get tired and you're sitting there
thinking of course you don't say it but
but Kadri how are you gonna get tired
you're not doing the lunging yeah and of
course that's the point and so you just
sort of do it until you know you don't
know till it's over
so that's so that's how you kicked off
the cue course is that the next thing
you're also I was in school next so you
know went straight from graduating boot
camp to then you know you're checking in
over at those barracks at Airborne
School and that's three weeks and and
then I got the made the trip to to Fort
Bragg North Carolina so I drove from
Benning to Bragg and checked in and so
part of the 18 x-ray program is is that
there were preparation courses so you
know Special Forces selection is no not
at Camp McCall but there was a prep
course that happened at Fort Bragg
it's a prep course for selection correct
because you're coming just off the
street or how long was that that was a
three weeks man and were they trying to
teach you anything or just rying to get
you physically ready so the main skill
that they had to show you was rucking
and land navigation so all land
navigation for us is 45 pounds dry in
the the pine forests of North Carolina
and you do a lot of rocking but but the
skill is how to how to use map and
compass in order to find points and
besides that they just there was a lot
of training quote quote to get us ready
for for the real selection which is what
they're making you hump basically yeah
well no there was a ton of of PT I mean
a ton right in that period of time and
these were so part of this was you said
this was called the
Rep course this is called Saab C so
special operations preparation and
congressional and so what was really
really cool in other words get some it
was just get some all the time and and
so what was really really cool though
was you had this was early 2004 spring
of 2004 and our cadre were some of the
guys who had been first into Afghanistan
mm-hmm they were the horse soldiers in
there that had literally come back those
are the guys that I wanted to be they
were my heroes and everybody gets
uncomfortable if they're sitting here
Abbey Hardison say you're my hero bro
right but you know I'll tell you that
they were my heroes cuz that's where I
was in life I mean they had they had
gone and fought the Taliban for us to
avenge what happened on 9/11 and now
they're telling me to go run and rock
and do push-ups and half the time
they're doing it with us because they're
about to go back to war I mean the way
this works is you come back and you do
some time as a cadre as an instructor
and then you go back on on an Oda on an
operational detachment alpha an a-team
if you will and you deploy again so you
know they were gonna stay in physical
great physical shape as well they didn't
do everything with us of course roll
around in the gig pit do all that stuff
they'd spent their time doing that
already but you know how do you not how
do you quit on them I mean these are the
things that went through my head I mean
it was just
do people quit during the prep or just
so it ended up being the prep the prep
course was a lot harder than actual
Special Forces selection for me and for
most of us I mean the pass rate for
those of us who went through this prep
course was something like 95% and how
many people did you start the prep
course with and how many people washed
out the prep course there was
significant I don't remember all the
numbers exactly let's say we started out
with 200 and not you know maybe 60 past
or something the prep course and then
all 60 of us passed selection I mean it
was something to that effect right now
you just everyone go through the prep
course no it was only for the guy
straight off the street and so the the
army would pull mean any job you have in
the army you can put your packet in to
go to Special Forces selection you don't
get to go to the prep course because
you're supposed to no rucking and land
navigation or you have to train on your
own to you know you want to do that two
jobs one paycheck you figure it out and
you find time when you're at your unit
deployed in Korea to go rock and to
learn land nap because it's or to stay
proficient and and so yeah so the prep
course ended up being it was one of my
favorite schools in the whole army I
mean I just halogen how much did you
guys rock
it was just would you guys Rock every
day so short answer is if it's not every
day it's just about every day and and so
for us I mean the the mechanics of the Q
course are all land navigation based in
the pine forests of Fort Bragg you
always have you start out on the kind of
timed iterations it's 45 pounds dry
right so that means not counting water
not counting consumables stuff like that
but land navigation meant you know you
go from point A to point B point B to
Point C and when you meet cadre at the
various points or you meet them at the
end and you show them the codes that you
found on the the spots that you went to
whatever the case may be they verify
that you did the route correctly you're
doing all of that with a rucksack on so
you just learn the way of the rock mean
and it just becomes a an extension of
your body you're moving with that ruck
and it is just a really powerful
experience to have that with you and to
get so strong with that ruck on your
back all the time and then there's rock
PT you know you take your Alice pack and
you put it above your head and now start
lunging or you know your it's just the
ruck is just your thing it's you have
your rifle but we didn't do a lot of
marksmanship stuff in the Q course at
all I mean there's a couple days at the
range but once you get to your once you
get to your team there's a ton yeah you
know but everything is just with the
rock and then you advance to patrolling
and the rocks get even heavier and then
you
you know your MOS phase I went and
became a communication sergeant so it's
awesome
radios teen echo 18 echo exactly so that
was radios and stuff but you know there
was rocks and honey I was already min to
and I didn't go to the 18 echo course
but I went to the the seal equivalent at
the time which was out on the East Coast
and yeah well to say that you carry a
lot of weight is a very broad
understatement batteries don't weigh
nothing radios don't weight nothing just
like bullets and and all of that stuff
and they don't weigh nothing so you have
to get comfortable moving weight and
they don't explicitly teach you how to
rock this is one of the things that I'm
I want to help impact that part of it
because they don't there's not a sit
down lesson hey this is how your body's
gonna adapt to rocking this is the
weight you should start at this is how
this is how you you grow that over time
they just say hey this is all the stuff
you're gonna carry go do it or do it or
don't right now
when you haven't put a ruck on for
awhile and like this is something I
always remember like let's say I was out
doing a close quarters combat or a mount
or something where we weren't really
wearing all rock and then all of a
sudden it'd be like okay well now we're
going to the desert and it's time to
rock up the firt when you put that thing
on and you take because when we first
played okay no factor and then probably
like the first 45 minutes of a rock comp
you go this is just gonna suck and then
over a couple days you're like okay this
is just the way it is and then
eventually after two weeks or three
weeks of that kind of training you
actually become accustomed to it and you
come used to it and that's where when
you're talking about getting strong you
you can you get strong your body your
body adapts to this this weight that
you're gonna have on your shoulders and
your back your hips and your legs I mean
the other part of this though is the
military takes the fun out of just about
everything okay they can't take the fun
out of camaraderie but everything else
like oh you want to go jump out of
airplanes it'll be awesome
it was Airborne School awesome because
for me it wasn't awesome no no
no right I mean want to go be scuba
diving master right was that fun Jocko
you don't know people ask me all the
time like so do you still dive like no
that was for me diving as being at 12
feet in the water complete blackness
staring at a communist for four hours
and freezing that's what diving is for
me like this every time I see like a
person in the tropics looking at fish
they're just like you know no idea
so rocking is not as simple as oh it's
it just sucks when you first do it I
mean the military 45 dry and you're
expected to move really fast that's a
that's not what I would recommend is a
beginners weight right now it's just in
the army that's kind of what it was how
good were you a trucking so I was not
good at a lot of things I was I had to
learn how to not overthink stuff uh you
know rucking was my thing I mean I'm I
got really long legs and it just it came
easy to me
so more weight load me up and you know
when we would go on our patrols they
would not put me at point right cuz when
you're that point you're sort of setting
the pace and getting the hey slow down I
mean I'm just my I'm six for my legs are
really long I don't you know other
things came a lot harder to me can you
win a sprint that's 200 a 100-meter
sprint will you win that no group
absolutely not will you win a where you
win a six mile run no I would I would do
okay
at the running part I mean there is a
cardiovascular part to rucking and and
at the time I would you win a ten-mile
Rock hump so I was I was always very
very competitive with that I mean top
few guys I I'm similar to that like I
was not the fastest sprinter at all I
was not the fastest you know six mile
run but with a rucksack on it was like
an equalizer for me and ended up are
fizzy a lot of physiological guys would
like yeah you have medium twitch muscle
that's what they said which they they
didn't really discover this medium
twitch they're like yeah you're not
super fast in a sprint and you're not
great with this long endure
but this thing where you have weight to
move and for a long time that's what
you're good at and I was like okay
that's cool cool with me and it was
really good for being a radio man
because I always had all this extra
weight and I could always kind of do
good with it you know and not that I'm
some stellar rock humper but he was
better I was better at that than I was
at sprinting I was better than that than
I was at the distance running and it was
something that was very I was very lucky
to have that because like I said
carrying a radio is uh socks carrying a
radio and if you're not like have if you
don't have some kind of propensity for
it's gonna be a real problem yeah I mean
you know the rocks are really heavy
I mean the the heaviest rock I carried
in the the Q chorus was 125 pounds we
had to jump in with that and then rock
that for a day and that was the
culminating exercise cold air held Rob
and sage and so when a lot of times
military folks will say rucking sucks
like yeah that kind of Rukn really sucks
right and then what you do is you you
show up to where you're supposed to be
and you dig fighting positions right and
you you know and then the cadre comes
and he blows you out of those fighting
positions with Artie Sims okay time to
go right and then you go and you dig
more fighting positions and you don't
sleep and you don't eat and you got a
rucksack on your back and you say man
rocking sucks like well it's not just
the rocking that sucks it's it's um
another one of those things where yeah I
guess the military makes it bad but yeah
when you get done with it you feel good
some of the best physical experiences of
my entire life have come after a long
ruck and you take that ruck off and you
sit down sort of the the rucksack flop
it's called you just sort of sit down on
the rock and then you take the shoulder
straps off and you can feel the blood
flow just going back everywhere in your
body and it's like your whole body feels
like it does after you take ski boots
off and it's just so awesome you can
just feel what you did I just love it
so how long is the communications part
you're like how long was the 1889 course
it was like three months and so it was
did you learn Morse code I was the first
class that did not learn Morse code so
it would have been six months week week
I look I had to learn Morse code which I
thought was completely stupid and the
guy that was teaching us the class was
like in the event of a nuclear holocaust
Morse code will be the only thing
punching through the ionosphere and I'm
like sounds good to me bro life has risk
right and when you're when you're
running the schoolhouse or whatever you
have to weigh however many thousand guys
a year is wasting are not wasting but
spending three months of other life when
the worst cars this decision if I wore
you know get me wrong I support this
decision it was not very didn't make it
a lot of sense when I did it so it's so
it's a three month school that you went
to it was three months and it was run by
these god bless em it was these two
third group guys named blade and razor I
mean just you run in your military
career and you have these instructors
that really just teach you things about
life and it's it's never because they
make it easy but they they give you a
y-you know this is important because and
you know they had just they were dive
they were dive guys with in SF which is
just it's just another suck school that
you go to down in Key West and it's a
real suck school not gentlemen this
course at all and you're already a green
beret and you go do that and then you
join a dive team and it's just another
sort of notch right that you have and so
they take their physical fitness within
our community even just a little bit
more and they come back and they
basically said hey there's gonna be no
slugs that come through this course ever
right and so I mean it was just you
would show up first thing in the morning
and blade would drive his f9 50 or
whatever was this thing was just
enormous and he was blasting his music
and he would say welcome to pain
roulette right and it was basically like
we're gonna play a song and you're gonna
do an exercise for that entire song and
you know when stairway to heaven comes
on you're doing push-ups that sucks
the thing was is he was doing it with us
it's like look I'm gonna go back to the
third group when I'm done here I'm gonna
take a team and we're gonna go back to
Afghanistan and we need to be ready and
you all need to be ready and those who
stress the the seriousness of the job
and the ways that you can become a
professional in your trade those are the
ones that you respect the most that you
you you yearn to please them because you
respect them and and that was how I felt
in that course so it was again physical
fitness was just the foundation and you
have to have it in the commune you have
to be able to do the work physically in
order to fight for your for your country
and so yes we learned some skills but
most of the training was kind of
outdated right we didn't deal with gun
truck setups we didn't deal with any of
the things that we were actually gonna
go do in war we learned the basics of
radio functionality and stuff like that
and we learned how to carry really heavy
ruck sacks full of batteries and radios
did you string up HF antennas we did
trees yes that was one of the go no-go
events and it's you know there's a lot
of excuses that you can actually claim
that our reality when it comes to being
a radio guy because how all that stuff
happens
it's sunspots and you know the universe
didn't want this conga other sunspot
cycle sir there's a sunspots in the AO
today and you know but ultimately you
have to just keep trying it's like
anything else you have to just persevere
and figure out how to make your shots I
used to be so kind of psycho and
fanatical about making coms
like that was my job and I was gonna
make comms and I had in one of my
evaluations it said made communications
100 percent of attempts and I was like
yeah because they they asked you know
they asked for us to submit bullets you
know like you know what you know I was
like an e4 and the teams and they're
like I said made communications 100% of
the time which I was very very proud of
because as you know that was not an easy
task to accomplish yeah a hundred
percent that's the state 100 percent
comms I was like because I would
be a psycho about and what that meant
was see what that really meant was I
would come up with communication plans
that had you know multiple backups where
hey look this this calm window didn't
work so that's then you'd bump to this
one and that one didn't work you could
bump this one so eventually I'm gonna
get comps I'm gonna make it happen 100
but so look did you gain confidence from
that of course of course you did right
is that the kind of confidence that you
you draw upon later in life when life
gets really really hard I mean all you
had to do is figure out how to move move
a little bit and you know make sure the
canopy wasn't covering wherever your
shots had to be made or whatever but
later in life life gets really hard and
you draw upon hey I know how to do this
I just keep persevering and I'll get it
we'll get it yeah uh was there anything
else in the queue course that kind of
surprised you or you had like trouble
with so it goes back to kind of
overthinking stuff and the the best
example that I have of this is you know
you learn the differences in ambushes
right techniques there's a linear ambush
and there's an l-shaped ambush right
there's sectors of fire and where's the
enemy coming from you know it's it's
terrain and all these various factors
dependent and the cadre there was you
know our team of say 15 or so and he's
giving us a class on this which is sort
of what you referenced an intro here
sure you have the opportunity to ask
questions don't ask questions you know
that kind of deal and of course I asked
a question you know college boy right
I'm like so Catherine I don't really
understand the difference or why we
would choose a linear ambush here
instead of an l-shaped ambush and it was
hey you go drag your face in the dirt
and until you reach that spot over there
and think about it because this is this
is the ambush as I've taught it right
and that was one of those moments from
like you know I'm not gonna ask any more
questions I'm just gonna do exactly what
I'm told and and that that took time to
really sink in and you know special
forces in theory is a place where you're
supposed to think critically and you're
supposed to ask questions and you're
supposed to do all these things and you
are
you just have to learn when to do that
and when not to and you have to trust
the judgment of the guys around you and
yet you know that took some time for me
and then the the other two big things
were that in Phil and Robin sage with
125 pound rucksack for a day and then
you know that that was that was horrific
and every Green Beret you ever talked to
if you mentioned the sage in Phil they
will cringe just a little distance I
mean it was all I remember is you may be
moving a mile an hour
I mean 125 pounds patrolling through the
pine forest and you're doing it for 18
hours so they eventually put me in
charge of the communication course at
SEAL team one and I only ran two of them
I think and we would weigh the guys on
insert it was a six day recon and they
would all be a hundred and twenty 110 to
130 pounds of gear and it was it was so
savage this course that I put these guys
through that you know when I look back
at my life I think man those guys were
ready for anything and this is like 1997
like there was no I was I was will say
wanted them to be ready and they were
ready they probably never got tested
that way again for the rest of their
lives
so I mean the sage info was the
culminating exercise of the Special
Forces qualification yeah you know that
you got to bring it right if you're up
there and you're setting the training
agenda you say this needs to be
something memorable and it was yeah yeah
yeah these guys came out of the field
like new people and and had they had it
was pretty awesome it was pretty awesome
these one guys lied to me and I they I
got up to there lay a point and I said
hey you guys missed a comm window what
happened and they kind of looked at me
and so I separated the team and I
started asking what kind of antenna you
know well no we were
for the common window we just didn't
make qualms so I was like oh cuz
meanwhile I'm monitoring everything and
they said someone groups I said what
kind of intend did you setup and one guy
said like a long wire and there's a yeah
I said I got what kind of Intendant did
you guys set up he said oh uh horizontal
die by pole or whatever and I'm like oh
that's not what the other guy said so
they knew they they just knew and I was
like get your gear ready get ready to
move out and they're like oh god so we I
had these guys hump to this water tower
on the top of a mountain and they were
already on the top of a different
mountain and then and then they got to
the water tower assumed they'd I didn't
let him put the rocks down that got up
and I was like go back to where you just
came from and they were like they went
back and then they get back I'm waiting
for him again and they come walking up
and I said to go back to the water tower
and I saw the look on one guy's face and
I said if you don't want to go you can
just throw your rock in the truck here
and we'll be good I'll take you back to
camp and the other guy was like negative
chocolate we got this and they moved out
so I was pretty stoked but yeah don't
lie to the cadre is what I'm saying no
integrity violations are a big yeah yeah
don't lie to the cadre and anyways you
know you can't move with a lot of weight
you know those guys humped those guys I
forget I measured out those guy put
those guys through a ridiculously
punitive road March and they still made
their extract which was cool yeah I mean
I think in the higher echelons of
leadership there there should be thought
given to how do you reduce the load of
soldiers because there's an inherent
bravado element that comes from being
the guy that carried 125 pounds that you
don't the idea we were borderline combat
in a this what's good about carrying 120
pounds is you realize hey this is dumb
this is not smart and if we got into a
firefight right now this rucksack is
getting left and we if we lose the
firefight or if we have to break contact
I'm never gonna see that thing again
with my radio with my water with
whatever else so yeah you should realize
that that this is dumb and carrying that
much weight is not going to be smart
you're going to be fairly ineffective
another time
we got to do it yes absolutely but you
got to really really think about it so
it's a good lesson from that perspective
to minimize the amount of weight that
you have to get like like I never I
would carry so little food mm-hmm I'm
sure you would like this too because we
just I mean as a radio man you had
batteries you got radios and I carried
water and like that's it and because I
would carry one MRE meal just the main
meal just that just that whatever that
main thing was I'd carry one of those
per day that's it that's what I go in
the field with because I could carry
anything else any extra weight just
didn't want it it wasn't worth it yeah I
mean so we just see though that even in
combat there's not enough there's
there's planning for everything you have
to have everything on you all the time
and you know speed is security right
that's one of that's a foundational
doctrine thing right the faster you can
move move the safer that is there's more
security and inherently and when you
weigh more you have more stuff weighing
you down you're not gonna move as fast
so you know I mean I think this is just
one of those things where in the
military some conversation around that
is good because bravado is great 125
pound training Rux great that's a that's
a lesson in the suck right we couldn't
fight with that it's too much yeah it's
too much so when you get done with a cue
course how do you guys figure out what
when you get orders
how do you got orders yeah so they just
tell you I mean so for us we also have
language training and stuff like that
language did you do so I actually passed
out of German and so that assign me to
learn German German from I lived in
Germany for about a year when was that
in college I studied abroad there and
then I had a buddy who was a he was a
boarder a exchange student in America my
high school and so I lived with him for
a summer while I was in college and
lived in their house and picked it up so
just passed out of the language portion
and so that got me to tenth group which
the classic area of operations is Europe
and then there's you know in the global
war on terror though you get pulled
everywhere and so ours ended up being
Iraq
so that's what it's that's when you
showed up there what's it like when you
get there are you just immediately put
into an Oda team you're supposed to be I
hung out on the B team for a little bit
because the for whatever reasons
sometimes you get not the best spot to
get put on and there's one B team that
supports all the a teams in a company so
there's six six OTAs or 6a teams and one
B team make a headquarters support and
so you know no matter what it's it's
like you graduate and you think you're
this great Billy badass Green Beret and
right and then you find out that in your
company where you're showing up
everyone's a green beret and they've
actually done stuff as a green beret in
war and you've done none of that and so
you know the the floors are never clean
enough the heads never clean enough like
that's your that's your job and you're
supposed to shut up and learn from the
people that are around you but so how
much time did you spend in the beating
five months and then we deployed yeah so
about five months and I went to some
schools in that process though they sent
me to a school called so TAC which is
the Army Special Forces equivalent of
JTAC so special operation terminal
attack controllers course so learn how
to call in in bombs out in Yuma Arizona
and so spent some time and went to a
shooting school and did that type of
stuff but didn't didn't join a team
until the the spring of 2007 in in Iraq
and then what was that deployment like
right so this was the you know this is
the surge right this was a messy time in
Iraq I know you know you don't have to
tell you that and we were down in the
south started out in Basra which was
just you know I mean for for people out
there I mean Basra was more aligned with
Iran through the Shia connection than it
was with the Sunnis that were coming out
of Baghdad right and an armored province
I mean so anytime historically Saddam
had issues he just sent his henchmen
down to Basra and show him what's up and
there was just a lot of it was just a
chaotic timing that IEDs so roadside
bombs and then
typically FPSO explosively foreign
penetrators right I mean yeah I think
it's a supposedly foreign projectile
penetrators it's one of those you get
the point right it's it's an AED it's a
it's a roadside bomb rather that would
cut through anything so it would it
would cut a hole through a Humvee like
you would cut butter with a knife right
and those were coming out of Iran and
that's that was sort of our AO and those
the the missions out of out of Basra
were just loaded with I I mean big
convoy stuff lots of IDs and then I got
sent to a team in that was operating in
out of Tullio Air Force Base so nas area
area so were you replacing somebody did
somebody go home did somebody get hurt
so they were basically alone as an Oda
and this is you know the early days of
this was a pic province so Provincial
Iraqi control basically what that meant
and you talked a lot about this in
extreme ownership was you couldn't go
out without the Iraqis the Iraqis had
final say the governor of the province
determined the missions that would go
out and so there was this one
Oda there and the regular army that was
stationed there was was not infantry or
they just didn't have approvals to go
out at all and we were working with the
local police force there so this by with
and through mission that was that's
that's what SF that's what special
forces is all about right is working
with local indigenous forces to achieve
a greater desired end state and so that
was our mission we were working there
and there it was it was not busy and
until it was but I got sent there
because they didn't have the ability to
call in bombs if they would go out on a
mission so I had this designator this
school that I thought it was a horrible
fate to get sent to the b-team when I
first showed up a group at Carson
because you know you can't be Jason
Bourne on the B team right you got to be
on the 18 guys and and so that is
another blow to the ego but what do you
do you suck it up and you do the best
job that you can and you learn how to
get you got to build trust the guys
around you so sometimes that means you
do a really good job of cleaning mopping
fleurs you do a really good job of
staying in shape you control what you
can control and people will eventually
take notice of that and they'll say hey
we want to give you more
responsibilities so anyway I'd been sent
to this school and had this designator
and got sent to a team in in Austria and
that's why I got sent out there so the
guys in Nigeria you guys are living in
like a little tiny fob of some kind so
we had rotated back and we were in a
bunker on base and this was one of those
instances where is it an Iraqi
controlled base or was an American
control no it was American control base
so large you know large runway stuff
like that for supplies and c-130s would
land there to take your pick there was a
hole we were just a 30-minute car ride
or truck ride you know the Hilux is
around the whole airfield and stuff and
but that was all there's a big American
presence there yes and then you guys
were embedded inside the wire with those
guys were there Iraqi troops with Iraqi
police in there too or were they in
another base so now they had their own
compound in town and this is one of
those things it was kind of a
coming-of-age story so they thought
right you know okay this is now a pic
province and the team before us had
lived with them and amongst them we
don't need you guys anymore go back to
your base well we got this we're good to
go and check yeah and it just it's one
of those things where then they wanted
cash and guns right we need cash and
guns in order to provide security in the
town and we were just you know paying
them and we were giving them training
which was just sort of part of the deal
and train them on basic tactics and and
all that stuff and that was our you know
we were just doing that did you guys do
what they do in raids or anything were
they trying to capture bad guys yeah so
to get to the sort of crux of this you
know it was it was quiet until it wasn't
and you know when you go to war you want
to be in war it's one of those things be
careful what you whisk what you wish for
but you want to prove your mettle I mean
it's just inherent and anybody
especially when you go through the type
of training that you go through in that
community you're you've either
and seen real combat or you haven't and
in you know to really earn the respect
of the guys around you you you need to
you need to do that so we wanted to do
that I mean I was knew some other guys
that had kind of been there done that
but they were comfortable in this
environment they viewed it as making a
difference getting out and doing stuff
in town so there was there was this one
morning I'd woken up from radio watch
which you know you always have someone a
radio watch 24/7 around the clock the
team rotates through and it was we got
an Intel or sorry the our local police
force called us and said there had been
you know an attack and they tried to
assassinate the Veii right had tried to
assassinate the the the police chief in
town who were training his troops he was
the colonel and we're training all his
troops and what it turned out to be you
know and oh by the way we need you to
come and help us
right because now they need us right
there guys are pinned down a bunch of
them got killed there they're in a
hospital in the middle of town and chaos
just chaos right so you know you start
to activate the intelligence networks
that you know other guys on our team had
been developing throughout that time and
you know the Intel that we got of course
later was that mikado Sadr Mookie had
sent down whatever 1,500 troops to
assassinate the local police chief and
rain chaos down on that part of town
Institute whatever he wanted to do to
destabilize the region and so our job
was to make sure that it would stay
stable I mean you don't want to give up
ground and war especially not a whole
city or else you got to go back and
retake it and that's that's really messy
you got to meet violence with violence
sooner so we had to you know go through
all these approval processes to get out
and to go out into the town and you know
with our partner force and it just it
turned into a it was a very wild wild
west type of so did you guys push right
into the hospital where they were
located well you know the crazy part was
the bureaucracy was still just rearing
in full swing we had to get the governor
to
of the of this province to sign
something that would let us go outside
like we went out to the the police
compound and then had to come back in
order to get this this signature or
whatever and you can imagine the amount
of complaining that's going on from our
guys like we're losing momentum here
yeah right you don't want to let more
people come in and take more ground in a
city and so you know we eventually got
to go back out and we had our partner
force there and you know we're just
working with the the guy who was in
charge of the the police colonel and it
was like we're pulling out a map on on
the hood of a Humvee saying where are
the bad guys like where are they and
then you get in your Hut your trucks
your gun trucks and you line up and you
know there's realize the the stakes here
there's three or four gun trucks and
there's you know 1,500 bad guys maybe
and that's that's a not good odds right
it's a rough one now that was the Intel
report and of course you know the the
headquarters is scrambling to get us any
type of support that we needed and you
know what we needed was obviously air
support and so that was my role on our
team was to ensure that we had cover
from above from the Air Force what time
of day was this during the day time this
was happening so it started in in the
morning this kind of spin Australian in
cup we would yes so well I kept going as
the radio voyage so it just sort of
extended through and and so then by the
time it really started to pick up by the
time we got to the hospital with our
Iraqis and you know we got our Humvees
and they got their pickup trucks and
there's you know it's how many home
these would you guys have in the 12 men
team I think we had three maybe four cuz
yeah three or four and then you load a
keys in the back so they had their own
pickup trucks really and so they're you
know they're riding around in their
pickup trucks and they got you do a song
Lux on yeah exactly and they got their
saw mounted in the back and you know
their windows are down and all that
stuff and you know at that time it's and
it still is but the IEDs were just that
was I mean it's the same destabilizing
battlefield force as a sniper it's just
such an
unknown thing you can do absolutely
everything right and you will just still
die no that's that's just the reality
that you face
and so at some point you know in this
process everybody has to say you know I
might die
I am absolutely 100% mortal I've seen
that this is this is very much a contact
sport
other guys playing and have died in this
contact sport and you have to just
remove that from your brain and you have
to go do your job and you have to be
smart and calculating about the risks
that you're willing to take because
there's this perception and I certainly
had it that Green Berets and seals and
all these types are just out there
taking all of these crazy risks to take
on these crazy missions and that's just
patently false there is so much risk
mitigation both through training and
planning and just the amount of time
that you spend working with each other
to learn tactics and techniques and
procedures in order to reduce risk to
achieve the mission and it's it's a it's
a lot different than what I had expected
and it's a lot more effective yeah and
to your earlier point you can mitigate
that risk you can train you can plan you
can do everything possible but you can't
mitigate all the risk and you can just
roll down the street and you guys you
can have a vehicle get hit with an IUD
and everyone in that Humvee can be dead
and that's what can happen war is just a
metaphor for life right war business
love and life are all the same thing to
me if you if you don't risk anything you
will not gain anything no risk no reward
if you're not willing to quit some job
you hate if you're not willing to tell
the girl that you love that you love her
and ask her on a date Romeo
right if you're not willing to go after
what you want most in life you're not
gonna get it there's risk involved with
that of what failure humiliation none of
those is as bad as as regret and we have
regrets when we don't risk anything so
make sure that the mission and the
purpose is worth the risk and do
everything you can to mitigate the risk
and then do everything
there's a lot worse things than dying so
you guys made it to the hospital so we
got to the hospital
you know we recovered there's a lot of
wounded guys that were pinned up there
they're loading them into the back of
the back of the pickup trucks and it's
it's dark out you know and there's you
know I'm scanning cuz my basic only job
really this is my second mission now I
mean its first mission out I mean
there's sort of some pseudo missions but
we didn't do sort of recon by fires like
you talked about with you know when you
had your your guy his first showed up in
Ramadi and he had this really complex
plan to drive all over town and you said
hey how about you go 600 meters out and
600 meters back or whatever we would do
that stuff but we just weren't getting
shot up so this is my first real mission
of any kind right and it was just you
know it was one of those things where my
only job was to focus on the aircraft I
don't know anything about conducting
wartime operations yet nothing there's
my first real mission so I just had to
focus on the task at hand and my job for
our team in order for me to not let our
teammates down was to do everything I
could to trust in the training that I
had and and make sure that the aircraft
was doing everything that they could do
to support us because they have a great
vantage point up there they can see lots
of stuff and if you've ever had a you
know hammer was the callsign the ac-130
gunship I mean that is just I mean that
as a battlefield asset is unrivaled its
unrivaled it is unbelievable yes what
Zac into the ac-130 I mean God bless the
Air Force literally I mean it is just a
vital support role that they play I mean
it you know there's this idea of you
want this kind of fair fight in life
it's it's more no you don't want that I
want an ac-130 yes that's what I want
the most unfair fight possible yes so
you know they don't play by the rules
the enemy doesn't mean the rules are
when you get into combat me there's a
reason all's fair in love and war right
all's fair in war there's no such thing
as unfair so I want I want a gun ship so
you guys had an ac-130 we had an age we
had a huge stack us I mean so you're
basically stacking all sorts of
different aircraft at different levels
did it turn out that there was this many
enemy fighters heading your way was it
1500 or was it like 4 d so we'll never
fully know what we do know is that the
the first building we started taking
contact as we were moving and you know
the local fighters we don't we assume
that they did not think that there was
Americans here right in in this section
of Hoops where they were oops is right
because you know the Iraqis also had
Humvees that we had given them and and
we're not here I mean like my favorite
color is red white and blue together in
the American flag that's my all-time
favorite color but when we go to war
we're not gonna go fly that proudly on
the back of our Humvees and say hey the
Americans are here right we're gonna
wait until you shoot at us from behind
and in front and then that big building
where there was lots of barrel fire
that's gonna go away right or it's gonna
have its gonna look like Swiss cheese at
the end of it and this was not one of
those very complicated wartime
situations I mean we were there to
support our partner force to provide
security in this in this part of the the
world and you know they had been shot up
by outside force and we were there to
provide stability when we're getting
shot at with them with us like that's
obviously an enemy trying to kill us
and our job is to kill you and that's
that's basically what it was but it was
you know a lot of rounds the city where
we would go back to the back to his base
and put the map back on the the trunk of
the Humvee and I would say where are the
bad guys well it's amazing what kind of
Intel you can get from from a source
when you're gonna help them go do
something that they need you to do right
though they won't know anything until
something like this happens and so you
know my job was
to to basically sit there and call the
coordinates up to some of the fast
movers so some of the jets and they
would go recon that part of town and
they would say nope no activity there
what's the next coordinate you want me
to go check out and then you know they
would say okay we'll go check out this
coordinate a point on the map and I'd
send that up and be like yeah there's a
war party there and so then we go drive
over to that war party and that's that's
how the night went there was a lot of
loops around the city and then you know
you pull back in to base and you got
that that chemical dump and you're just
sort of you see out there how guys can
go on these missions and then just fall
asleep it's not because you're just so
physically tired
I mean it's part of it maybe but there's
just this huge kind of okay we're back
on base or we're back wherever and you
can just fall asleep so quickly because
your body is allowed to relax of sorts
you feel safe again right and but we
come back and you know then it's right
back to the priorities of work you've
got to gas up the trucks because you're
going back out by the way because it's
not like one night you just the
multi-headed Hydra is just dead now if
that's not how it works but you know our
headquarters element had sent all sorts
of other a teams and but you know the
Iraqi commandos were there and then it
was for the week the next week it was
just a lot of actioning all sorts of new
Intel that came in and and yeah I didn't
end up not being some sort of martial
law type situation that we were fighting
but it's also kind of a doctrine based
thing where if you meet violence with
violence and speed of action you can you
can take back the high gran high ground
or take back the the town itself and so
that's you know who knows who knows what
would have happened if they would the
the insurgents would have been more
successful and would have taken over the
police compound and would have done
these various things who knows you know
then you've got a fight to take the
ground back yeah well they would have
taken over the compound the vehicles the
weapons that stuff gets really scary
really
yeah so then that so then you guys got
the city back under control this was now
Syria you said right nazriya yeah
and then once you had it back under
control that things kind of settle down
they did what the the interesting part
was that this is how we had developed
rapport with our partner force right so
when you do hard things with people and
you do them well and you build trust
with them then they want to work with
you and in that that cuts across all
different lines right so whether it's
Navy working with Army and Marine Corps
or whether it's you know us working with
the Iraqis and working with the
Australians that were on base at that
time as well and they were they were
great in support of the mission that we
were there as well and when you do hard
things you just develop a bond with
people and that's foundational in the
military and and so we found that we
were much more effective training them
we we were much more they were much more
receptive to the intelligence gathering
in their town and just working with us
in general and so then we could go on
patrols with them or go on missions with
them in their town going after is the
stuff that they wanted to go after you
know and that was effective because we
we were better at the tactics but they
were better they were better as the
first guys in the door they they speak
the local they have they know all the
local stuff we always found it funny
like early on in our deployment to
Ramadi like our breachers would go up to
a door and of course they look at the
door oh it's okay we can't open it cause
sledgehammer but sometimes they we just
have like these little Iraqi mechanisms
and like Iraqi soldiers walk up and like
push a switch or whatever pull lever and
the thing would open up be like okay
cool and and also like you just said
they could easily identify if this
person was from Ramadi and if they
weren't from Ramadi and they were living
in a house there they're probably a
foreign fighter and probably bad so but
we can't tell the difference anymore
than someone from
I could come here and tell the
difference between someone from New
Jersey and someone from Boston and
someone from Alabama like even if even
if your speak the language you don't
understand those kind of dialects and so
whereas Iraqi people the Iraqi soldiers
they'd walking back all this guy's not
from here
he's he's you know I always use the
example of what'd you have for breakfast
because they knew you know if you ask
what you have for breakfast in South
Carolina you get a different answer than
when you say what you have for breakfast
and in Maine right you eat different
things and in California like out here
it's like oh I had a breakfast burrito
if you ask someone from Maine what they
had for breakfast they're not gonna say
a breakfast burrito it's not happening
so yeah they can they can identify those
things so did you guys end up doing like
just for the rest of deployment you guys
doing just like targeted raised to go
and get rid of bad guys so ours was kind
of the full scale all-encompassing
Special Forces mission this was not some
hugely kinetic driven operation we
didn't have the commandos that was a
good mission to get that was not what
our team had right so the commandos were
a national-level Iraqi force and you
would assign one you guys it was your
partner force was a police force our
partner force was a police force and
over there I mean what's the difference
between soldiers and police you know
very little I mean in a lot of ways yeah
they carry around machine guns they you
know it's the differences one wears like
a blue shirt exactly and the other ones
don't
the other ones wear a cami top you know
that's kind of the difference you know
and so you know we were we were training
them up was your Iraqi police force from
Nigeria they were see that's another
that is another big difference is that
the local police forces are generally
from that local area which gives them
even more of a sense of what's going on
which is important whereas you know in
Ramadi the soldiers the army soldiers
were coming in from you know all over
the country coming in from Baghdad also
vastly Shia and so now you got them
coming into you know sunni homes inside
Ramadi so there was a little riff there
whereas the police or from Ramadi and
they were Sunnis and so they'd
immediately almost
a better relationship once we built up
that police force and when I say we I'm
definitely not talking about us just us
seals in fact I'm talking about everyone
else that did more much more of that
than we did but so you guys were were
more doing this full spectrum too you
guys are training him you guys are
teaching them how to gather Intel you're
teaching them how to do simple things
like logistics and all this kind of
thing we're also running our own and
then there's a guy on the team who is
his job he's the intelligence sergeant
and he's running you know assets and and
all that stuff in the town and so you
know it's the by with and through
mission so we're gathering Intel in town
through random sources of not random but
various sources and then what you try to
do is you try to train your force up by
doing stuff right you don't just oh gee
on-the-job training exactly
you don't just gather all your Intel and
just keep it to yourself you need to get
your force out doing stuff so that they
can gain confidence from doing stuff in
life that's how this works and so it
just sort of turned into hey you know
here's some here's some intel on this
and then we would go out with them and
they're the first in because that's what
you want
I mean you shouldn't think unless you've
got some really high value target where
you're gonna send in your own very best
guys because failure is not an option
we've bin Laden raid is of course a good
example you're gonna send in the people
you're not gonna let your partner force
go in first
no you're gonna take care of after
neither you're gonna tell your partner
force exactly and you're willing to live
with those consequences because it's
that important in this case you know
this was part of the coin strategy the
counterinsurgency right you you need
these local trained up police forces to
go out and be able to police their own
areas and it's less sexy in some ways
than hey I got my beard and I got my
guns and we're gonna go after bad guys
in every single night but it's a lot
more effective train-the-trainer
and so our job is to go out there and
basically show them how to do this and
this is how you here's the tactics and
this is what we do and so there the
first end and
you know you get good if you're a cop or
you're a soldier it's kind of the same
thing there's that's why there's such a
bond even in America between cops and
soldiers you you go into a house you can
smell what that house smells like and if
the hair on the back your neck stands up
it's probably not good and you can walk
into some house and you're like nope I
can just tell this isn't it well their
sense of smell quote quote is a lot
better than ours and ours is pretty good
at times but they're able to go into a
house and you know by the way the the
doorways are really narrow there's 25
people sleeping on the floor you know
half the time they're on the rooftop
naturally because it's cooler it's a hot
country right so how are you kind of
assessing you got everyone's got a
rooftop so if you're dealing with
aircraft above who's on the rooftop it's
not like they're up there as snipers all
the time they're just on the rooftop
persley think they're sleeping kids yeah
with their kids and so it doesn't work
to go in to these places with with your
you know just guns and do more than you
should and so you know part of what what
going through elite style training
brings is the confidence to know when
not to pull the trigger when to assume
greater risk to your own life because
you should not just go out and pull the
trigger and the more confidence you have
in your weapons and your sense and
that's really important and it's a much
more stabilizing presence there if you
don't kill a bunch of innocent people
right it's there there is collateral
damage in war it's just it happens but
you have to do almost everything that
you can to minimize that because the
second third order effects of dead women
and children are not good yeah that's
the the US military goes through
incredible lengths to prevent that from
happening and you know and you're an
environment that this is a good example
you know nazriya at that time this is a
good example it's like a transitional
phase and I mean when the Marine Corps
pushed into nas area in o3 it was you
know like a legitimate war battle going
on
and now you fast-forward four years it's
a different situation it needs to be
handled with more discrepancy so so
that's yeah that's that's the way it
works out which is the way it's supposed
to work out that's where
counterinsurgency is the the level of
violence gets less and less over time
and hopefully well hopefully it does and
then also hopefully the the capabilities
of the host nation forces get better and
better and eventually they reach a point
where we're not needed anymore
that's what's supposed to happen that's
what's supposed to happen you know it's
what year is it or 18 years later yeah
yeah well I mean we made some you know
we we got Iraq to a fairly stable
position and unfortunately we completely
left in situations like what you just
talked about that's a classic situation
where it's like all of a sudden whoa
we're about to you know we've got a real
problem here and when we left there's no
one to call when we're still there we go
okay cool cuz what we just said is hey
if Sadr Stroup's had come in and taking
the police building down and gotten
those weapons and gotten those vehicles
and now they're gonna start to empower
themselves over the people inside that
city that's where that's where you have
a real problem that's kind of what
happened with Isis after we pulled out
of Iraq so yeah that's what's supposed
to happen but you have to continue to
provide support to that host nation
because even once you mitigate the
levels of violence as much as you can
you need to make sure that they're gone
and that takes a long time that could
take ten years it could take 15 years
we're still in Germany you know we were
in Japan for a really really long time
and so these things can take a long time
and they shouldn't be you know if we
would have stayed in Iraq in after 2010
if we woulda been there in 2012 2013
2014 if we were to just stayed there I
bet those guys I mean even Lafe who
wrote extreme ownership with me and he
went in 2010 and in all of all Ambar
province when he deployed with SEAL team
one in 2010 in all of all Ambar province
for his six-month deployment there was
one friendly casualty and it was from a
vehicle rollover and you compare that to
when when he and I were there in 2006
when there was
casualty or two or three or four or five
every single day just in the city of
Ramadi so we were heading in the right
direction I mean that's a massive switch
but again if you if you assume that okay
well it's good enough and now we can
just walk away that might not be the
best policy so you need to think through
those things a little bit better than we
do I think some of those decisions were
made based on political decisions based
instead of based on you know everybody
that was on the ground that was saying
now no we're not quite ready to leave
yet need to give a little more time need
to need to stay keep our presence here
be a backup force you know be able to
support the local Iraqi soldiers and
police if they need it which they
probably won't I mean they already they
already said hey we don't need you guys
that was 2007 they said hey we don't
need you guys live with us anymore
that's cool in Ramadi they weren't
saying that they wanted us there and
every time we turned over a police
station to them I think oh well I think
every single time that we turned over
completely a police station to them in
2006 you got overrun so they weren't
ready for that yet so it's gonna take
more time eventually in 2007-2008 they
turned over all those and there was no
more coalition forces outside in the
city who was all Iraqis so we can get
there but a counter insurgency takes
time and you have to you have to give it
time you're not on you know it's kind of
like kind of like standing on the dang
cables at Airborne School this is you're
gonna have to do you have to stay there
until it's time to until it's done till
it's ready
yeah I've been take some time then you
start to get into what's the expectation
that people back home have for how long
this should take and how much does it
cost and is it really worth it and you
know I mean it was just a really it was
just a really hard time you know my it's
and it's it's also hard when you're
fighting and my family was hugely
supportive and yet at that time it was
all about the casualty counts the body
counts of American soldiers in Iraq and
you got a lot of moms and you got a lot
of moms who can really relate to the
moms that are suffering from losing
their children and
I mean what's the what is the desired
in-state like what is our actual goal is
it is it to turn Iraq into Germany I
mean if so good luck or is it
we don't want places to be able to
export violence
I mean destabilization I mean I I kind
of never fully understood what the
actual desired in-state was that was
realistic
yeah well America did a bad job of
stating what that was and clarifying the
mission and clarifying the goal and then
they also have you you also have to be
able to explain that look as we dive
into a situation our expectations are
going to change and to your point when
you look at an Iraqi army unit let's say
or Iraqi police unit if you think that
you're gonna turn them into a Western
military unit or a Western police force
so you're not going to because they have
a different culture but what you can do
is figure out how an effective police
force or how an effective military unit
fits inside their culture and then they
can can do an excellent job but you have
to you have to be malleable I don't like
for instance just the way that they
would gather Intel and we'd be trying to
teach them how to do their Intel
gathering and it's like actually let
them these people know how to talk to
their own people they don't have to
figure this stuff out they know how to
document it let them run with it and
instead of trying to force our
methodology on top of them take
advantage of some of the some of the
cultural advantages that they have
inside their own country let's do that
so you you have to be able to adapt as
you see a situation unfold but then you
have to just like just like as a leader
when the priorities change as a leader
with your team you have to explain to
everybody hey okay I didn't see this
coming this is a little different than I
thought it was gonna be a little
different than we thought it was gonna
be here's what we're trying to make
happen now okay
everyone says ok let's let's move in
that direction so I I think not only
does did Amer
do a bad job of coming out of the gate
saying hey hey okay here's what we're
trying to get done right now it's also
okay look
didn't really see this coming here's
what we're gonna try and get done here's
where here's the direction we're moving
now this is what we're this is what
we're gonna do and we did not do a great
job of explaining that to the public
because man when I went over in 2006 and
it was the same way in 2007 like you're
talking about the public opinion had
massively not universally but a lot of
public opinion had turned against the
war for sure that was the TV that was
you know an entire half of the country
was I go we shouldn't be there okay so
how do we explain to people okay if we
don't want to be there what do we do to
leave what's the best way to leave how
do we get out of there how do we get out
of there in such a way that it doesn't
turn into a problem again so these are
all things from a really grand strategic
perspective that hopefully we can learn
lessons from and you know I'm sure
you've seen some of the reports coming
out of Afghanistan right now about what
what was being said on the ground and
what was being told to America and
there's obviously some really stark
contradictions between those two things
and it's horrible to read about you know
you can look at the entire Vietnam War
and you know what the whiz kids were
saying about Vietnam and about hey all
we need to do is kill more of them than
they do of us and we'll eventually win
it's like no that's not actually true
and you know this is one of the reasons
that you know I've got my kind of
personal mentor who have never met
before but Colonel david hackworth who
came out at the end of the Vietnam War
and said you know if we don't change the
way we're fighting we're gonna lose and
he got drummed out of the army and no
one wanted to hear that and even even in
the 90s he was viewed by the army by
some large portions of the army as sort
of a traitor strong word but they saw
him as sort of a traitor well he was the
guy that was telling
the truth he was the guy that was saying
listen we're not doing this right and if
we keep doing this we're not gonna be
able to win so these are all things that
yeah as a nation leadership military and
civilian communicating to each other
openly and trying to work together to
find solutions trying to work together
to adapt your your mission to something
that's achievable to something that we
can do to something that's worthwhile
these are all things that we need to do
a better job as as a country for sure
yeah so relating back to Vietnam and
then to Iraq though to to our country's
credit and this gets nobody ever likes
to say hey America great job right but
when you sit and think about how far we
as a nation came from Vietnam where they
would spit on soldiers when they came
home to Iraq or half the country
disagreed with our presence there in
2006-2007 around that time frame I mean
there was still separation between who
soldiers and Marines etc and the actual
support of the war and in that you know
I felt very supported and and so as far
as I knew did every everyone that was
there with me did as well just the
American public was not taking its anger
out on us no American has definitely
learned an incredible man from every
perspective now that meant everything so
you know I cannot imagine what those
soldiers went through in Vietnam when
they would come back and it was just
they were spit on it's can you imagine
it's insane to think about it's insane
to think about I mean I covered a book
on here guy came home with a severely
wounded arm you know and he goes to
college and sure enough he's he's you
know getting called baby killer and all
that and you just think to yourself wow
that's that's just unbelievable and then
you had Jim serves Lee come on here who
is in Vietnam was a soldier in Vietnam
who on in his 11th month of his
deployment to Vietnam stepped on an ie D
lost both of his legs like basically at
the hips almost lost one of his own
and I don't know I don't know if a human
being can face adversity
let me put it this way if that guy is
not a model of how to face adversity I
don't know who he is because he came
home did nine months of rehab got done
left his rehab went to college got a job
started a roofing company started doing
real estate
and carried on with the rest of his life
I mean just like the most unbelievable
face to adversity and you know what we
got plenty of other guys on here that
have been incredible just the way that
they face I mean Travis Mills I don't
know if you know Travis Mills is but you
know he's a quadruple amputee that the
guy is his his just unbreakable spirit I
mean just facing adversity every single
day that we can't even fathom
we can't even fathom the tiny little
things in his life that he has to
struggle with that he wants to never say
a word about and he does it and he
carries on and and when you meet him you
think man I wish I could be as happy as
as he is
I wish I could go I wish I could get
along in life as well as he's doing
right now so a lot of that does come
from the fact that America learned it's
lessons from Vietnam at least from the
perspective that you just gave which is
we treat our servicemen and women with
respect regardless of what you feel
about the war okay got it but we treat
our servicemen and women with respect
which is a which is a high praise for
the way that we are operating America
now for sure I think it would be great
to even take that one step further and
just those who serve those who that's
the fabric of what makes America America
strong communities we have aligned
purpose our values are really clear you
know as an American as as America what
we stand for and and yet there's a lot
of people that make that happen at the
local level there's teachers there's
fire there's cops there's
first responders there's all sorts of
people that work in also dangerous jobs
out of DC and and it's just we need a
call to service in this culture where
there's just a lot of emphasis and value
placed on being the best individual we
need to reawaken those calls to where
it's it's a very noble thing to go and
serve your country
yeah and I'll tell you right now I mean
the idea that you're gonna get real
satisfaction from taking care of
yourself it pales in comparison to the
satisfaction that you get when you help
other people no doubt about it and if
people don't understand that you know I
get I get asked sometimes you know well
I don't know what my next mission is I
don't know what to focus on I'm like
okay if you don't know that cool go help
other people go down to a damn soup
kitchen and volunteer and and you'll
start to figure something out and if you
don't cool you're helping other people
either way we're in a better place
because of it it's kind of
counterintuitive though it is because
you it's so people and I I did this as
well we struggle to make that connection
where we say I've got to be better me me
me now how do you do that is you find a
mission and if if you have a purpose and
then you have a mission on top of that
purpose that's you're hitting homeruns
regardless of that if you just dedicate
your life to serving something greater
than yourself
it just it opens up a way of life that
leads to a lot of great things with a
lot of great people and I just I've
never met the person at the end of their
days who said you know I was just
I served too much I gave too much to
other people I wish I had just done more
for me me me I just haven't met that
person and so you know we have the
ability and the potential to change our
lives for the better with just a mindset
shift though just to say we dedicate
yourself to it to a greater cause
there's lots of ways to do it the
military
a very romanticized way in especially in
our society we you we uniquely love our
military and I do too and there's just
it's not for everyone and it doesn't
have to be and it shouldn't be so
instead of kind of using this old the
military only affects one percent of the
population like it's some sort of
judgment on our entire country that's
okay
the military is one percent that's
that's awesome
right and if it needed to be more it
would be but it's one percent that's
okay there's a lot of ways to serve and
and that's where the bridges between the
Americas that we love that represents
the best America and where maybe we come
up a little bit short from time to time
if we just dedicate ourselves to serving
instead of to being angry at the TV news
at night like ghosts turn the TV off and
go find something to serve that will
benefit your community in our country go
do that that would be helpful yeah but
you know instead it's lemme let me see
how many dopamine hits I can get through
my brain from the likes that I'm gonna
get on Facebook if I go publish some
anger ridden ad that's divide and
conquer tactics where you're just a pawn
you're a pawn someone's someone's
written some article that's that's gonna
just divide people and we share that
stuff and people like it and we think
wow I'm part of a community that's
that's talking about these important
things how about you go stop doing that
first and how about you go do something
that actually helps other people and I
don't sit here saying this is all I do
with my life I don't just you know go
from orphanage to orphanage right all
day long every day right I'm I'm human
like all of us and yet you know when I
have these kind of this these times when
I think and reflect usually outside with
a rock on like am i doing what I can do
to make my community my community my
country stronger because I just I feel
like I owe and and that's the the
that I caught through through service I
did not foresee that I thought it was
going to be about me me me getting my
revenge for what happened over 9/11 and
what I got instead was this this really
basic primordial reaction that I just I
owe more and I can't shake it and I'm
grateful that I can't it makes me just
want to keep doing the things that are
rewarding and that involves other people
and building communities and building a
bridge between the military and civilian
worlds instead of using these divide and
conquer tactics yeah so how long is this
deployment to Iraq to take us back to
Iraq how long were you over there that
was 2007 and nada seven months so you
guys ruined like a seven-month rotation
right and then we we came back and that
was coming back was a weird thing I mean
we stopped in Shannon Airport and
Ireland and drank a bunch of beers in
the airport there because we had rented
a civilian aircraft and there's just a
bunch of Green Berets that flew back so
there's sort of a mad dash for the bar
we got there and and uh you know then we
got back and my car was at Fort Carson
my car was the same place where I'd
parked it I disconnected the battery you
know the battery was I had to connect
the battery back we're sort of in this
parking lot around our compound at 10th
group and it was just sort of like oh I
guess I I went to war and came back and
it just was kind of it was kind of weird
and you know there was this other
compounding part of my life which was
you know I was married to Emily and we
had started dating finally told the girl
I love the love of my life that I loved
her oh and oh by the way I'm going to
boot camp right so we had gotten married
while I was in the queue course and she
had then gone through the CIA training
pipeline to become a case officer she
graduated from to become a case officer
five days before I became a green beret
right and so she got sent to Africa and
then I got sent to Colorado and then to
Iraq and
you know talking over secure lines with
your wife and while you're at war and
she kind of had some access through her
friends to some of our situation or
sitreps situation reports from war and
there was it was just kind of it was
surreal but so I also felt just really
kind of lonely I mean our team was there
but then they went off and they had
their families their families greeted
them and that was just kind of it was a
lonely ride and oh by the way right when
I get back I have my truck and driving
off base
think thankfully I waited to this off
base but you know in Iraq when you're in
a Humvee and you're driving you go down
the middle of the road it's a tactic
because most roadside bombs are on the
side of the road and you don't want to
go anyway you just you you just dominate
the road that's how it is get out of my
way I've got a bigger truck than you do
and that's what's happening and so I I D
faulted to that on the highway right off
Fort Carson and it wasn't some sort of
Oh huge flashback or something it was
just kind of I wasn't only a habit I
wasn't home yet and it was just all of
these all these weird emotions going
through my head and I had to kind of
click in my brain and say hey I need to
slow down stop stop flooring it because
that's also how you drive there speed of
security it goes fast as you can to get
to the target right and move over into
the right lane take a deep breath it'll
be okay and and that's more than the
actual fact that that happened was just
the weird feeling that that happened and
then you know I didn't have a cell phone
setup or anything and all that stuff it
wasn't quite as simple as it is now so I
went back I was staying with my great
aunt and uncle in Colorado Springs and
then I called you know had a calling
card number to call Emily she was at
working out of the embassy and in
Abidjan West Africa and it was just sort
of this I'm back and it was it was very
anti-climactic just to be
the phone it's not what you see in the
movies where you know you land and
there's the big parade and and all of
that stuff and you know the your loved
ones sprinting for you and you know you
swooped her off of her feet and do all
of these things it was none of that and
then you know then the next day what do
you do you go back like the work go back
to work and inventory all your stuff and
make sure that your team rooms clean and
and do all of that stuff and that's you
know that's the next couple weeks of
your life and so yeah so that and then
eventually obviously I saw Emily I flew
over there for for Christmas that was uh
that was the kind of vacation because
she's in war-torn West Africa
it almost was more comfortable to go
visit her oh you felt a little more
normal
well it was like you know so we talked a
lot about PTSD and all that stuff this
day and age and it's become this kind of
thing where every veteran probably has
it so I shouldn't hire a veteran or
there's something wrong with them I'll
donate money but I'm gonna kind of put
them on the leper colony and let them
struggle with their feet ESD and send
them a paycheck every once in a while
that's that's the situation at its worst
now there's there's obviously various
levels of that but it's just you know
when you came back from war and say
World War two you know you're on a ship
with everybody that you went to war with
there's decompression time whereas for
us you know we're getting on a plane
we're having a couple beers and Shannon
we show back up at home and then we're
at home and this is America and it is
very very free right and you know
there's not trash everywhere people
don't just I mean in Iraq everyone's got
that what 8 foot wall if you've got in a
house and any money you got 8 foot wall
with concertina are probably barbed wire
around the top of it and when you have
trash at your house what you do is you
walk out in your front yard and you
throw it over your wall because you
don't really care about what happens
outside your your little wall well here
it's just you know that Colorado air is
pretty awesome and you know you can stop
anywhere you want and there's no
roadside bombs and you know it's like
what you saw in in Hurt Locker the guy
goes in and he's staring at all the
cereal and there's ten
a cereal that's not the decision that
you're used to making and it feels weird
just it's it's gonna happen so fast and
and so I remember I got off the tarmac I
was on the tarmac in Abidjan and I'd
flown over there you know they love a
good COO in Africa this it's always kind
of semi permissive and it's never
perfect and they could have RPGs and aks
in the street at any time and you'll be
the last to know right and so it got
there and it just it smelled tropical
and it smelled just sort of like like
not America and rolled in and it's just
there's just all this commotion at this
African Airport and you know riding back
getting in her car you know gave her a
big hug and a kiss in the airport and
they got in her car and drove home and
there's checkpoints and you know there's
guys with guns at the checkpoints and
and then pull into her house and it's
there's two layers to the compound and
she was not on an American compound per
se was American housing but not a
compound but it was within a compound
with other locals and there's one layer
of quote security where there's a local
with a pickup truck and if you're white
you're you're fine to go in I mean it's
it's just how it is there it's and so
you know so we drove in they obviously
knew her in her car at that point and
then you know she's got a second layer
of quote security and it's a rent-a-cop
basically and they've got a stick you
know they're not doing anything with
that stick but it's it's faux security
and but it just it it felt more normal
to me then coming back to America so
quickly and it was just sort of some
decompression time but then you know
you've got the sort of relationship side
and life's hard and and so you know
she's in that job I mean the CIA works
its people really hard you have a lot of
people young people old people whatever
that sort of America that work really
really hard and that are true patriots
and they're really committed to our way
of life in America and if you go that
route
you are it's a 24/7 job just like
Special Forces is and so she's working
100 hours a week by Wednesday are its it
was not a traditional marriage you know
and was it alright we getting through it
was separation a good thing sometimes
you know the best thing that can happen
between some couples is they're not
around each other sometimes that's
horrible it doesn't work yeah so we had
spent you know the first four years of
our marriage we did not live together
at all zero living together I was at
Fort Bragg's she was in Florida teaching
she was a eighth grade Spanish teacher
right so for the first year of the QED
course I'm driving back to Florida every
single weekend that I have also if I'm
not in the field I have the weekend off
so drive back you know second year she's
going through she's working out of
Langley and then you know out at the
farm and so kind of doing some of
driving north five six hours every
weekend to go see her there and then you
know she's in West Africa and I'm in
Iraq and then I'm in Colorado and it's
you know your yridians were the thing
back then you know these sort of because
it wasn't as simple as everyone's got
data connections just pull up FaceTime
or Skype or whatever the case may be so
you know it's yridians and there was you
know a strand of probably a hundred
numbers i had to dial to get the access
to get to call her cell phone or her
whatever at her at the Embassy and if
you go to the well too often eventually
the well runs dry and so when that
Christmas it was just kind of weird with
her it wasn't bad
like we she babysat my siblings growing
up she was great friends with my family
and my mom and all these things like we
really were in love and and so we knew
each other as friends for almost a
decade before we started dating and it
just was kind of weird when that that
Christmas and so it was kind of like
okay I was going to get out of the army
in October of the next year and it's
like okay well we that became the target
right everything's gonna be better at
that time and so you know was there for
a month and we had fun is just was kind
of weird like life was kind of weird
though too
right I mean she's in kind of war-torn
I'm going to war coming back flying over
for some quote vacation you know and
we're finally together and there's just
so many balls in the air it's hard to
make sense of what's going on
and so we went back and you know back at
base well we ended up forward deploying
to Stuttgart to do a backfill for our
our commanders an extremist force that
was in Stuttgart
so was stationed there for I want to say
four months something like that but in
that time also went down to a different
part of West Africa on a mission to work
with the Mauritania noops out of new
auction except we were in a cute which
is you know a few hours through
literally camels in desert and in
Mauritania and you know we trained up
there commandos and we were out there
and the interesting part is that in much
of the world you know the US has its
diplomats and it has its soldiers and
there's kind of a stark difference
between those two in much of the world
you know the soldiers are where it's at
you know the the diplomats they don't
have the real power because they can't
they can't take their soldiers and go
drive to the middle of the capital and
say hey I'm in charge now
and so you know to go back to follow up
on some of the earlier points about you
know should we be in Iraq or Afghanistan
or I think special forces in some
capacity should be everywhere special
operations and people who are serving
this purpose of working with other host
nations I mean that was also the lesson
of post 9/11 Afghanistan was you have no
presence there you're gonna have to
recreate it in time of crisis and that's
very challenging and so to have some
some presence between militaries between
hey the US military has is working with
these locals that are in the military in
pickier country that's important because
you you it's constant not like spy stuff
but you just
that's it and that's a really positive
thing very positive and so you're also
able to be there just in case and so in
those kinds of countries you know
there's a role for there's definitely a
role for the military anyway I was there
and even while I'm on that deployment
you know em flew up on African Air or
whatever from a bichon tuna walk shot
and my captain gave me the time off to
go you know hang out with Emily in the
capital new Oakshott for a couple days
while she was in town then our whole
team went to a soccer game there in some
Chinese built Stadium because the
Chinese are moving into Africa big time
but they they move in and they set up
their own base and they bring their
thousand Chinese and they're not doing
anything with the locals except
extracting what they can from there and
they're building relationships that way
with with money and with their presence
and they build soccer stadiums and the
locals love soccer and that's kind of
what it is anyway that's a bit of a
tangent but it's just to say that our
marriage was kind of it was a typical
and so you know I went back and when I
did not a cart of the reason that you
decided that you were gonna get out of
the army because this you know your
marriage your wife being in the CIA
being on deployment traveling and you
being into doing the same thing and in
the army was just gonna look long-term
that's just ain't gonna work
we just knew it wasn't gonna work
long-term the hope at the time was that
it would we would be able to sustain it
until it sort of ended now what I did
not foresee was the idea of how much I
loved serving in the Army Special Forces
and how great and and what an honor that
was and and how impactful those men in
that community were and will forever
have been on my life and that became
something that I I dreaded leaving that
job and it would sort of just felt like
this guillotine that I was facing as
you know cuz it's not like you just show
up one day and you say alright peace out
guys like you have certain dates and you
have to re-enlist prior or you do all
these things and you know they were
really trying to keep guys in because
they've invested a lot in us and you
know the mission wasn't stopping and so
it everybody around me understood what
was going on with my life my wife's in
the CIA she's in West Africa we can't
make this work
it's just not possible to be married in
these kinds of jobs or roles in life and
so everyone was supportive but at the
same time I felt like I was quitting and
so I started to go through that process
and eventually obviously did go through
that process and when I pulled off base
I had my same green Nissan Xterra
I'd had throughout my whole training
life in Fort Bragg and then a Carson and
your car is just this very safe place
you know when you can turn the AC on if
it's hot if it's cold you're warm it's
it's this small notion of privacy you
don't have a car in basic training where
you have zero privacy but when you have
a car you have a little bit of freedom
and you know if you're able to use your
car for whatever reason before formation
or just in general you have so much that
is just creature comforts and drive
driving off base in Colorado with
basically everything I owned in the back
of that truck and I just I cried on the
way off base and I couldn't believe it
because this was supposed to be this
really positive step in my life I was
gonna go get reunited with the love of
my life and it was gonna be it was
supposed to feel different and I already
just hugely missed my my team I missed
that way of life and I'm I'm I felt like
I was abandoning them and they were
gonna go back to war and I wanted to go
with them
and I was you know uniquely
uniquely I was well-trained in America's
eyes to be on the front lines and to
continue to serve and I believe in our
mission and regardless of you don't
always get to choose the destination
that you go and that's fine right I
believe that
when America says it's time to go I want
to be the kind of person that says send
me and so that that was the sacrifice of
the individuality that I was very
willing to submit to the team into the
mission into our country and it just
felt like I was losing all of that and
and so you know eventually your tears
dry and you wake up and you you learn
how to be resilient again but it was
just it was where did you go where was
the plan right so I drove back to
Florida where my mom was and I was just
gonna put my stuff my car and storage
and then I was I was getting on a plane
to fly to Africa
to go live with Emily because you know I
was now her dependent right so it just
was a typical because I had not gone
with her out of the gates I mean it was
you know you're supposed to be together
that's kind of how this stuff works I
mean a community of - that's a
foundational community sometimes it's
you and your dog sometimes it's you and
your family but it's that's a community
and and that is very important and not
only my life but our lives and so you
know that was the plan drop my stuff off
get on a plane and fly over well I did
that and it was just as weird as it was
that Christmas before it was just a lot
weirder just everything was it's just
nothing felt right and you know I didn't
have mission or purpose and she you know
she she was used to operating alone I
mean she was her and her dog Java mm-hmm
right and so you know that was her life
hundred hours a week by Wednesday 24/7
all the time and then I'm showing up
almost like dead weight because I got
this I got this sort of chip on my
shoulder because I just gave up
everything to be with her and you know
it was just very it's just not fun
ya know this sounds like a nightmare
because you're showing up there you just
got out of Special Forces you just got
back from these deployments and you have
been turning and burning working 20-hour
days for the past however many years and
then you show up and she's in the middle
of that exact lifestyle and you like I'm
gonna watch more TV right now this is a
nightmare
it was horrible like there was nothing
to do right so I even applied for jobs
at the Embassy I'm thinking how do I
serve for the next year because she was
gonna be there for the next year how do
I do something here for the next year
and literally the only job available
that I could get was as the janitor of
the embassy and I'm as referenced
earlier I'm not above mopping the floors
and cleaning the head I was not ready
for that at that time in my life though
that's just not what I couldn't go from
this this thinking that does this vision
that I had for myself and for working
with these guys on this team - I'm the
janitor of pushing them off at the
Embassy and oh by the way you know my my
wife's on the top floor in this you know
really cool job she's saving America
yeah on the front line front lines and
um and I'm doing nothing but cleaning
log head in so that flicks didn't even
exist at that time so there was Armed
Forces Network was all that we got and
you know so then it's it's me and Java
at the house right and this is where
this was the beginning of my life
turning into that bad country song where
a guy's got his dog and you know his
sort of bottle of whiskey and all of his
sorrows and you know I ended up only
being in Africa for about two months and
then I it was like word this just isn't
worry this is too miserable to endure
and it wasn't sort of like we we didn't
hate each other by any stretch and oh by
the way I'll get to the point somewhere
down the line where we got divorced and
then we eventually got back together
we're together now right so
it's even ten times Messier but at this
point you know we were just really good
friends and we had gone to the well for
too long and I just didn't I wasn't a
part of her journey and she wasn't a
part of mine and we were trying to make
it work and we said okay well we'll skip
to the end and that just didn't work and
so I'm then I'm flying back to solo and
we were you left were you like yeah this
is did you leave on hey was probably not
gonna work or did you leave on like okay
well I'm gonna go figure some stuff out
in America she's gonna stay well you
guys still thinking is gonna stay
together at this point hope is not a
strategy and we were at best hoping and
it just it felt like a sledgehammer so
when you rolled out were you kind of
like yeah this is probably the end of it
or do you not want to say this on the
air right no no I mean I think it was
just our very it was just very confusing
I mean for me and this was very mutual
by the way this was not all me or all
her this was both of us and it was you
know she didn't want to she didn't want
to bend her lifestyle for me I mean was
she thinking she was gonna stay in the
agency forever at this point right so I
mean this is how this was the ultimate
irony was that you know part of the
journey that I wanted was to go join
ground Branch the CIA that's where it
started Mike Spann you no rest in peace
when when we honor our heroes it will
inspire further service and and that had
inspired service in me and so I didn't
know anybody in that process of hiring
to get to ground branch I didn't know
anybody and I eventually started and
made it through and became a green beret
and in Emily's training I met lots of
people in ground branch and they became
friends of ours and so it was kind of
hey why don't you just come back and go
through the process and that's how it
works right if you know someone you're
more of a trusted person and especially
in that place the the agency's always
looking for things to do with spouses I
mean if you can because you're already
trusted mm-hmm right I mean there's
risks in that job of leaks and all that
stuff but you have to trust your spouse
and so it it felt like okay well I guess
I can go do that
and so started reapplying for some of
that stuff but frankly I mean I was not
in the I didn't have a headspace at that
time - I went from hero to zero real
fast and I'm sleeping on my buddies
slanted floor couch you know apartment
with a slanted floor on his couch in New
York and the Lower East Side for four
months I mean he's a bartender
most of the only times I'd leave the
place I'm going for his shift to you
know drink free booze at where he was
working I mean like it was just it was I
mean call it what you want some state of
depression or not having mission or
purpose in in my life and feeling like
now I don't have no job no mission no
purpose no wife which I was kind of
banking on as the foundation for the
rest of my life you expect something to
go a certain way and it doesn't that's
harder than just knowing that
something's going to be miserable the
whole time and so it was just one of
those things where em and I stayed in
touch we even you know took a trip to
Morocco together and it was still weird
and then eventually you know she came
back to eventually you guys need to go
to a place like Hawaii or you know the
Bahamas just keep going random African
nations that are in turmoil yeah might
want to thank you that but it's so I'm
annexing from Uncle Joe Bear the other
part of this is I'm actually
insufferable on a beach with nothing to
do right and suffer like what am I
supposed to do you can surf I wish I
could you can try I can try you're right
it can be really bad at it until I'm
less bad the same places without
security checkpoints is what I'm
advising yeah God ain't your reference
so we're kind of you know in touch again
and doing this weird long-distance thing
and it just it just kept getting worse
and worse and worse and it's sort of
confused she comes back to America and
has Java and Java formed a really big
bond with him while I was in Africa
because he was kind of my only friend
job and Francis Francis was our our
housekeeper and sort of
almost like Em's chief of staff for the
house she would have parties to over the
house or she would host people or
whatever and he was just make that train
roll and I became really good friends
with him and he was my best friend in
Java and I was at the house all day and
for a period of months and this is any
way really fast transition to doing
nothing and having no purpose so
eventually she comes back and it's still
really bad and we're just sort of
subjecting ourselves to further misery
right but you say you hope oh this is
gonna get better it's gonna get better
how's he gonna get better right I mean
something's got to give and then
eventually you just you can't endure it
anymore and so it's like you know she's
like hey I'm done and so I went through
that I stalled that because I'm the
eternal optimist right I mean this
everything can work out if given enough
time and and and then it almost becomes
a competition of who can suffer more
right and I I think I can suffer a lot
and I'm willing to kind of be that kind
of martyr if left to it if left in a
situation where I want what I want I'll
suffer almost anything and so eventually
you just move on and you know I started
Business School which I had applied to
and I also had this little hobby for
GORUCK that was kind of nothing at that
time but she had actually recommended it
the first time I went to Africa because
I built her a go-bag I built her a go
rock and that was a something that then
I just was applying what I did in war
you have a go-bag he put it in the trunk
of the Humvee in case your vehicle gets
disabled and you got a fight right so
you have bombs and guns and batteries
all that kind of stuff and it's just
extra supplies that you don't want to
have on your back all the time and might
as well have more if they if the trucks
gonna carry it around with you so or for
you so I have done that for her and made
one at her house and made some others
for some of the other
folks that she was working with at the
Embassy and when I was trying to figure
out what to do we were trying to figure
out what I could do
she's like you should do the GORUCK
thing and that just kind of meant teach
people what you know from Special Forces
or building go bags or whatever figure
it out like here's something do that and
that idea kind of stayed alive as I came
home and but I was not in any position
to commit to anything as significant as
kind of starting a business and going
full throttle and yeah so so I'm
sleeping on my buddy's couch and I'm
kind of trying to figure out okay well I
got this GORUCK thing and I'm applying
to business schools and I'm applying to
the CIA which is just another real
process it nothing happens fast even
when you're a spouse and I'm still
technically a spouse so it's it's easier
and I know all the right people
through through Emily which you know cuz
I'm her dependent now like we joked cuz
one time when she was at the farm and we
went to her
we went to Busch Gardens in in
Williamsburg and we got a discount on
the the entrance because we're active
dude I was active duty military and she
was my quote dependent right it's it's a
military term like it's not a it's not
like we're equals Emma and I are very
much equals and always happen but she's
my dependent legally and I was then
later her dependent legally but at Busch
Gardens they gave her a necklace that
said hero dependent she loved that yeah
I mean we both just sort of chuckled
about it it was it was uh she turned it
over to you like eight months later
where you got out here you go yeah it
was in a box somewhere like everything
else I still I still have it in my work
desk yet now I go rock and it's it's
something that makes both of us smile
now but so basically I had these these
kind of I'm applying for more stuff
trying to do something I mean the idea
of filling out an application to go to
grad school was
a hugely daunting task this should take
you know two or three hours it was
months indecisiveness in inability to
function and you know we talked about
military transitions are hard like
whoever you are if you lose all of your
support structures everyone's got a
breaking point I mean this is one of the
lessons of sere school survival school
no matter how tough you think you are
you are breakable and you know all of my
support structures were gone and but
GORUCK became a hobby so I had this idea
for okay well I guess I'll try to figure
out how to design a backpack or a
rucksack and thankfully I actually
unbeknownst to me almost knew a lot
about this topic I just sort of
gravitated toward it because I knew a
lot about it even though I didn't have
some conversation that said I really
know about rocking and rucksacks I did I
I was not my own in boosting my home my
own you know sense of self-worth through
something that I thought would be a
great way to spend time it was just
something to do and so you know didn't
know anything about manufacturing didn't
know anything about anything but
eventually it was like okay I got I'll
start doing something with this put an
ad in Craigslist New York City for a
backpack designer and like alright well
let's see what we get I got kind of some
sketches and I got some samples and I
want something that's kind of like these
and got a response back from this team
in Montana that was basically trolling
the internet for work because in 2009
the economy was not in a good place so
you have to put yourself into those
kinds of perspectives you know youyou
like to say good about a lot of stuff
you know bad stuff happens good well
look the economy was in a really bad
spot
good good if you people are looking for
work good if you're trying to do
something awesome because there's a lot
more opportunity whereas when nobody's
looking for work and everything's really
expensive and you can't find any deals
because the economy is just purring
forward it's just it's harder you gotta
you got to speed things up faster so
anyway I found this great team out there
and basically worked on the
and how to do them throughout my first
year in business school and then when
did that develop into or how long was
Business School so Business School was
from 2009 to 2011 and so even Business
School is I applied to a couple schools
and it's like I don't even know if I
want to go to business school I mean
it's like it's so weird to think about
now I've got these chapters in my life
and I look back at them and it's hard to
relate to myself now in some of those
chapters it's like when I I think about
deploying to war and all the training
that I went through and and the people
that I served with it feels like I'm
reading my own book sometimes write my
own kind of narrative in my head I don't
wake up like Rambo everyday or anything
you know I've taken a ton of lessons
from that but I don't I don't like I
also can't relate to being just
depressed like why don't you just stop
being depressed that's what I would sit
and just stop doing this and the right
answer is move forward any way you can
if you're feeling sorry for yourself go
do something for someone else and you
know eventually em came back we sort of
separated our ways we fought about this
is in the middle of Business School so I
went to business school at Georgetown
because they gave me a full ride a
scholarship right in no small part
because of my military service and that
was one of those decisions in life a
lucky break where they just made the
decision for me like you mean how do you
conceivably turn down a full ride to go
to business school at Georgetown well
the answer is you don't you you you send
thank-you letters and you're very
grateful and you know also the post 9/11
GI Bill and you know transitioning
veterans out there you should use that
it is a great way for you to buy some
time and react limit yourself to America
and gain a skill some knowledge some
whatever and its structure and so I'm
grateful to the American taxpayer for
you know they pay for some housing
allowance and some books and it
distressed my life a little bit at a
time when I needed less stress in my
life
and so going through business school and
an M and I had gotten you know
officially divorced but she was waiting
to go on another assignment she was
gonna go somewhere else down south
either Brazil or Mexico or something and
you know she had Java and she's living
in a hotel in DC because she's only
supposed to be there for a few months
and Java was the fight between the two
of us is the only we never fought about
money we we always loved each other we
were always friends but Java was the
fight because there's not two javis and
so you know that I'll never forget this
moment where I was staying and I had a
condo in not too far from Georgetown the
University in Georgetown and she was
staying at a hotel on P Street it's a
hotel Palomar because his dog-friendly
and we're sort of have dual custody of
our dog Java right and it's like this is
what we both got really emotional about
because he had been with her II he was
kind of her dog but he also was kind of
my dog and he had been on you know so
just to put some of her work in
perspective you know she's going as a
hundred and ten pound girl out to go on
termination meetings with assets meaning
you're telling them you're not gonna pay
them anymore
which is their only lovely hood in life
thanks for your service and the the
intelligence that you got us but we
don't need you anymore that that's
you're threatening someone's livelihood
be very careful how you are around them
and in her case there was Java in the
backseat with fangs at the ready should
anyone get elevated or you know
escalation of tone temper or whatever
Java was back there and he was very much
her protector and they had obviously a
very close relationship as well and so
it just got so bad about Java she gave
me a really big hug we were standing on
the sidewalk off of her hotel so a
little bit closer towards the Georgetown
side on on P Street and she goes you
need him even more than I do
so here you go
and then you know then it was Java was
mine and and you know I felt guilty
right and it was just really I didn't
but I was also barely still took I still
took him you are absolutely right I
still absolutely took that dog and that
dog is uniquely responsible for my
turnaround in life so because here's the
thing you need mission you need purpose
you need community you and her dog
that's a community of two and that is a
lot that is a million times better place
to be than a community of one which is
not a community at all right it's even
the military side of if there's two of
you you can cover 360 degrees of
security if there's one of you you can't
you're alone and that's not a good place
to be in life you need other people we
are hard-wired for this and it is better
for us to be around other people and so
now I have Java and you know dogs have
to do things like go to the bathroom and
Java needed exercise and he would let me
know and no uncertain terms that he
needed to go out and that he wanted to
go to the creek and that he wanted to
then go a little bit further down the
down the path and you know I just I
poured all of my grief into that dog and
I felt so much better for it and then
you know you start you take one step and
you can take money and and so that was
just the start of kind of slowly and it
doesn't happen like that it's like when
did you become a great leader I mean if
people ask you that you really it's like
it doesn't work like that it doesn't
work like that you've got to just take
one step forward and see where that path
goes and when when you're at a low spot
in life I mean get a dog work hard stuff
like that I mean Java got me out and was
just my absolute rock in life for the
next several years and he passed away in
2013 got sick and passed away of
something we don't know what but anyway
by that by that point I was doing much
much better and it used the time in
business school to kind of incubate
rock and met a lot of people there that
that hugely impacted the the direction
that GORUCK would take so how did GORUCK
get to get from this idea of teaching
people about it go back to what it is
right now yeah so it started out with
one rucksack gr1 and you know there's an
I did a napkin sketch of it and
eventually figured out how to get that
through the process of you get something
or indeed and then you find a factory
that will build it which is by the way a
completely different process and then
there's things like order minimums and
you have to spend all I spent every
dollar I had to get any inventory at all
and the thing is is at that point that
was May of 2010 was when the the first
rucks were for sale and I thought man
we've been working on this officially
since you know the original idea was
late 2007 officially started the company
in February of 2008 is just a way to
while I was in while it was still Green
Beret that's just a way to catalog costs
like oh there's I gotta take a trip here
I gotta pay this person to design these
things I guess it's a company but I
never had a lemonade stand as a kid okay
I was not some eager entrepreneur like
this is what I have to do in my life I
just kind of backed into this and then I
have a company and then you know it
starts to kick in I hate to lose I hate
losing hate it right and so I don't want
to I don't want to quit on this I'd have
already quit on a marriage that's how it
felt I already quit on a team already
quit on what I held most sacred in life
and that's what it felt like and so I
don't want to quit on this so I took all
of my kind of perception of failure and
I had my dog by my side and I just
refused to quit at this and so in May of
2010 the rucks came out and I thought oh
this is awesome I spent a lot of time
developing this everyone's gonna want
one of these how are you going to keep
inventory up with this demand
it's just gonna fly off the shelves like
mad yeah
I mean I can't believe I thought of this
I'm so brilliant yo you know the name is
great the every pixel on our one-page
website is perfect and you know it's
silence was the world's answer it just
was absolute silence and nobody bought
anything and that's like man this is
terrible so I had this great by great I
mean horrible idea to drive around the
country to 48 states by the way with my
dog Java and go meet anybody I could
meet that would possibly be interested
in buying a rocks like I felt like Willy
Loman
except I wasn't selling shoes and Death
of a Salesman I'm like selling rucksacks
out of the back of my truck which
actually everyone needs shoes everyone
doesn't necessarily need a rucksack so
you already started at a rough spot so
did that drove to 48 states and went to
sort of small retail shops and got the
Heisman from everybody right like no you
know arm out front this is too expensive
you know the retail price was 295 bucks
for a rucksack and they're all they were
all made in America and they're it's
just really expensive when I first saw
the cost side of what it was gonna cost
like this is insanity and and basically
it was so luckily you knew that everyone
would want these exactly so the question
became what I did not know how to do was
anything related to business doctrine I
don't know anything about online
advertising I don't know anything about
wholesale I don't know anything about
ads I don't know anything but what I did
know how to do was to work with this
these designers and they they gave me a
heck of an education in just the
manufacturing world and I'm just
grateful that I found them just a huge
education about all the trade-offs and
product and you know what you can and
can't do and that became my foundation
they became teachers to me for two years
as we were developing this and
eventually
got a great piece of gear and that
wasn't enough though and so went back to
the beginning back to the basics and
said what what do I know how to do
because I didn't want to slave over a
computer and figure out Facebook ads I
just didn't and I I should have probably
except maybe I shouldn't have because
what I did know how to do was to teach
others and how to how to train others
and how to build teams and I learned
that from the guys who had taught me
that in Special Forces and then working
with them by with and through partner
forces in Iraq and in Africa and so came
up with something called the GORUCK
challenge which was a rocking based
event imagine that because that's all my
training was and now we have rucksacks
and anybody could sign up and it would
be led by a special forces guy and at
that time it was just me and so you know
it was sort of details not forthcoming
and you show up at 1:00 in the morning
and this could go very long time there's
no published route
there's no published distance it's just
us and you're gonna do what is is you're
gonna do what's told if you lunge around
the building till I get tired styled
right and yet the other part of it was I
didn't want it to be like boot camp that
was the one thing out of the gates was
yelling and screaming has its place but
in boot camp and because you have to get
people's attention and you have to tear
them down you just don't have that time
when people are actually giving you
their time and paying you to be there so
you know it was we weigh the rucksacks
down and they would put bricks in the
rocks and then we would do PT and a
guided tour of the city and they would
face a lot of adversity and I would just
apply the lessons that I've learned in
my training to building a team out of
this small crew and then that started to
expand yeah so what turned out to happen
is that those people did the work for me
they went on Facebook and Google and
used their networks and told people
about go rock and oh yeah there's gear
that we manufacture like a foundational
level we did
and manufacture all of our own gear and
it's meant to withstand this really
difficult and challenging stuff and its
really good at carrying weight all the
things that I would have wanted out of
an assault pack that's kind of what we
did with this we just sort of
streamlined it so it didn't look like a
military assault pack right and and so
what here was that first GORUCK
challenge that was September 25th of
2010 ok so it happened pretty fast when
is the next one happen so the next one
happened the next month and it was
basically in it was in DC after the
first one were you like okay this might
be a path right tire ice I was in the
parking lot of like right along the the
ocean just west of Golden Gate Park in
San Francisco they have you know parking
for beach access and that was a start
and end point and it was I don't know 12
or 15 people were in that first class
and where'd you advertise on Craigslist
or so we had a partnership with a an
event series called Tough Mudder and and
so we were actually meant to be the
prequel to the Tough Mudder that was
gonna happen in Lake Tahoe in that
region like a little Fight Club if you
will that would then show up and do the
Tough Mudder together as a team there
and it was something for them to talk
about and it was obviously good for us
so they had they had hit a home run on
there their first event which was in in
May of yeah it was May of 2010 because
that's we went to that as well got
together a bunch of my Special Forces
buddies and put bricks in our rocks that
we had and went and did Tough Mudder
together and it was sort of something to
talk about
and of course nobody bought anything we
had inventory that's where I thought
everyone's gonna buy everything nobody
bought anything I think one person named
Neil bought one rucksack at half off
right so I almost got my money back or
so for further rock and it was just you
know so anyway we had kind of attached
ourselves to a bigger organization and
they drew we got a little bit of their
press and so people showed up and but
that first one I actually had a really
hustle to get people out there because
it was just a proof
concept and it was crazy this idea of
unknown distance unknown time
unpublished route and some Special
Forces guys gonna put you through
Special Forces style training that was
the marketing and so that will speak to
a certain kind of person the question
becomes how do you reach them and you
know Tough Mudder certainly helped in in
that and then you know you get one
person that signs up and they want to
bring a buddy and that's kind of how
that worked and and so did the first one
and and you know we went over Golden
Gate Bridge and back and yeah they rode
around in the sand and did you know all
that Navy SEAL style stuff in the ocean
that I was less familiar with ocean PT
so you know there were a couple you know
hey I had to learn how to make sure they
locked arms when the masseur was coming
right like lock elbows in everybody make
an unbreakable chain well that became
sort of the teamwork part of it and when
we were done we hung out in that parking
lot and drank beer together for hours
and everyone was just sort of had this
huge smile on their face and you know I
brought some peanut butter and jellies
and people were eating that and drinking
beer and everyone was smiling and we
were talking about how bad it sucked you
know and it was just awesome it was like
this is how we're gonna build GORUCK
these are our people you know the people
that want to push a little harder
a little tougher demand a little more
and want to be around just have that
sense of camaraderie just push a little
harder find something hard and do it
because it's hard it's very
counterculture these days right
everything is sold on being easy and you
know we build gear that's designed for
the toughest situations on planet earth
like war and we put on events that are
designed to challenge people and push
them harder and and now we have a lot of
different events but at that time that
was it and it sort of made the rounds
and the people that did it they told the
people that they thought I know because
when you're done you say I know just the
person that needs to do this right and
so you know the next one was again a
really small cost like six people in DC
four of whom were personal friends of
mine but it was a value roped into
randoms though
to random right I'm gonna probably you
know and at that time the the price of
the event was half the price of the
rucksack and you got to keep the
rucksack so I'm making no money
on any of this and I'm spending to
travel and go places but you have to bet
on yourself sometimes and you have to
bet on something that you believe in and
I felt felt it in my gut that it felt
really good to give back to people to
show them not only what this bridge
between the military and civilian worlds
look like but but just as individuals
how to push a little further in life in
this small microcosm of Special Forces
training and you know that was very just
rewarding so come what may this is what
I want to do I don't I don't want to sit
in front of a computer and figure out
how to do Adwords I don't that's not I
want to be out and use and I'm gonna
lose that fight I'm gonna lose because
there's people who they just grew up on
that stuff and they've been doing it for
forever and that's sort of fighting a
war on their terms a business war now I
wanted to fight this on my terms and my
terms were I have this background and I
can apply what I know and I can provide
real value to people if you're starting
a business think about that first
provide real value get real feedback
from people and and follow that do more
of that and good things will happen and
so there was some startup cost to this
though you know traveling around and you
know it's the events were 12 and then 14
hours and you know they were really
really challenging and every single time
it was like a little Fight Club that
happened and there was just a very
passionate base that became the
foundation for this GORUCK community and
if that would not have happened I would
have gone back and figured out how to
serve America in some other capacity you
know ground branch or go back into the
military or whatever I mean that's what
I wanted to do but I just got that sense
of satisfaction from from this so that
you have your first event in 2010 how
many events are planned rough
we for 2020 ten years on so we have
about a thousand events a year now and
they're they're led by current and
former Special Operations guys and so
that means just we have seals Green
Berets Delta guys we have you know PJs
from the the air flow we have all you
know we have force reconnaissance
Marines and what's important is
empowering veterans to give back on the
homefront because all of us are united
in this belief that we oh we owe more we
owe you think back to the friends that
you lost and when I say that I know for
a fact in your head you're thinking
about them right now and you think that
they died in service to our nation for
values that we hold dear and what they
wanted to do was to continue doing that
for the rest of their lives that's what
they wanted to do and so we honor their
memory by continuing that mission as as
US and we get huge inspiration by
drawing upon the fact that we oh we just
oh them and not just for their memory
but but for our way of life and the
generations that will follow because if
we don't honor their memory then we'll
forget and not this doesn't mean just
write it down and forget about it it
means you have to live it and you have
to talk about it and you have to share
what you've learned and you have to get
out there with other people that maybe
have not been exposed to that and you
have to you have to show them what that
why that matters and why service is so
important and for me that the
inspiration is the guys that I served
with and that that way of life that they
taught me and so everyone in our
community has that we have that deep
inside of ourselves and this is just an
opportunity for those
in our community to build a bridge
between the military and the civilian
worlds and to get that feeling of making
a difference on on the home front
and so GORUCK became this bridge for me
I was part of the building of this
bridge along with the people who showed
up for these events we were building it
together along with my dog and every
every event I just my the well that was
empty in my life it just filled up a
little bit more and a little bit more
and a little bit more because I gave
back what I knew and people said thank
you
if someone says thank you take them at
their word you did something good do
more of that this is doesn't have to be
that that hard right and so that that is
something that we're just passionate
about we put veterans as the face of our
organization at all of these events all
over the country and the world and it's
just it's there's just a little bit of
magic that happens and we're all we're
all strengthening and reinforcing that
bridge and it's it's a very different
thing than than getting angry and
talking about how different we are I
just I don't see it I see we literally
don't care if you are young old black
white male female gay straight military
civilian pink purple polka-dotted
striped whatever right if you want to
show up and be a part of this team and
do the work we want you on our team
that it's just that simple and there's
something very liberating about that
it's a political it's it's pure and and
that's what the military in its best
form represents there's just absolute
purity it's it's to be a part of that is
just it's great and so to be able to
lead that for others is just hugely
rewarding
yeah that's powerful I got another
question for you lessons learned wise
how did you manage to get your wife back
yeah that's a good one
so what was it so um in you took her dog
I took her dog she you're just fat and
like real low right now I was so I was
soon as no job you're going to school
you're mean you took her dog alright how
did you manage to dig yourself out of
that hole so I was so desperate to Emily
she gave me her dog right so she moved
down to she moved down to South America
got remarried had had a daughter Natalie
who lives with us now still visits her
father her father's in the military in
Brazil so he's a Brazilian officer and
you know I mean that's just sort of what
happened at that time but the chaos
train continued a little bit for both of
us and it just it was it wasn't just
easy there was just it just wasn't easy
and you know I'm driving around with a
dog to 48 states trying to start a
backpack business good luck by the way
right
against all odds you know and you know
she fell in love got remarried and had
Natalie who's just the world's greatest
big sister now cuz we have two other
boys or two boys I should say Jack and
Ryan but so how did we get back together
you know we just kind of stayed in touch
we were always friends and it wasn't
some kind of what happens when you make
decisions in the moment is that when
they're when they're big decisions and
there are Forks in the road and you you
go left or you go right or one of you
goes left and one of you goes right I
mean eventually you will get perspective
on your own decisions
and you have to come to terms with that
and the thing that I really try to avoid
in life at all costs or regrets and I
just I don't I think about will I regret
this with either my time or my effort or
energy whatever
before and this is fast-forwarding to
just sort of business or life or
whatever decisions but at that time you
know I don't know I really don't know
what it was I remember she wanted to see
Java because she was back in America one
time so so we met and I saw her and we
had Java and it's like we're crying
again I mean it's just the the love
never really dies I mean you you fall in
love with someone I hear these stories
you know you love someone and then you
hate them because whatever um that's not
my story
right my story is we were really good
friends for a really long time and we
hoped that our strategy of having this
fairytale ending skip to the end with
these chaotic crazy lives which then the
plane was I was gonna join the agency
where we were gonna be a tandem couple
and the agency and that didn't happen of
course right but we stayed in touch saw
Java and then at some point she was she
sent me a handwritten letter which is a
really you know it's one of those things
that if you want to get someone's
attention in a very busy world send them
something that you've actually written
by hand it it implies a degree of time
and thoughtfulness and all these things
and so we traded a couple notes it's not
like this is just radio silence but she
sent me a note and you know it was just
like I I'm moving back to America and I
would love to see you there's probably
more to it I don't want to you know it
was it was complicated but you know I
mean and then we saw each other and it
just kind of clicked again like the love
came back and and the love never left
but it was I don't know Jocko is just
magic it was just magic and it's just
one of those things where the surprising
thing I guess was that you know she had
gotten remarried and she got divorced
right and then we got back together and
you know I had not moved on I mean I had
dated other people
and and yeah I wasn't really ready to
really move on I had not gotten over her
by any stretch and so that kind of held
me back in lots of other things
especially the the love department of
life but I also was very skeptical I
didn't really want to just throw myself
back into what our relationship was in
2008 and 2009 and so it took time after
that we it's it was actually you know
work we had to talk about stuff and get
stuff out there imagine that like if
you're gonna get remarried to your ex
why have you you've got some work to do
right and and uh you know now we have
two boys and she works at GORUCK as well
and it's it's not some perfect life that
everyone thinks that everyone else has
because nothing is perfect but we're
really happy awesome
one last thing I wanted to ask you about
is the I know you you and I kind of
linked up to begin with through Ryan
Mannion and the and the Travis Manion
foundation what's how are you tied into
supporting that unbelievable cause in in
memory of of Travis yeah so that was one
of those situations it was one of the
easiest some things in life are really
hard and you've got to do them some
things that are hard in life you should
not do because there's probably other
things you could spend more time on this
was one of those situations where they
do at their core the very same thing in
so many ways right they empower veterans
to give back right they they operate
from this assumption of wheat we oh we
oh and let's be servant leaders and
let's get out into the community let's
be more physically active let's build
communities let's show the next
generation what our values are and let's
let's allow them and afford them the
opportunity to become servant leaders
themselves and so our community
basically linked us up I mean there was
a Heather who work
at Travis Manion foundation was doing
GORUCK events and TMF for Travis Manion
foundation was was putting on these
hero's runs over 911 every year to get
people and bring them together in honor
of the their cause
right and and so it just kind of
happened I mean the the communities
they're doing service projects we have
communities the communities just sort of
aligned and then we partnered officially
on these 911 heroes runs and turn them
into rocks or runs or walks whatever but
it's about bringing people together and
you know raising awareness and spreading
goodwill around the the veteran space
and so you know we had been working
together as partners on this stuff and
service stuff at the community level
ground up long before I ever met Ryan so
you know since then I've gotten to spend
a lot of time with her and we just
rocked the Marine Corps Marathon
together which was awesome yeah it was
great you know you you spend some time
with someone doing something hard you
get to know them and it's great you
develop a bond and that's you can't get
it if you don't do something hard
together so that was great and we just
share a lot of the same values and so
you know they're part of our vessel for
fundraising and for getting people out
and getting people active and aligning
around a cause and one of the things
that I love about her her story in the
story of the Travis Manion foundation is
that she goes Travis would hate the fact
that we've called this organization the
Travis Manion foundation because you
know she's like it's not about me right
that's the sort of way of life that you
live and you really do live it when you
serve in these kinds of communities in
the military and and so their other
their their other thing that they say
these last five words that he said
before his or these five words he said
before he deployed on his last
deployment to Iraq was if not me then
who and you know the way he said it it
wasn't really a question it was just I'm
gonna go because this is what I'm
trained to do and if not me then they're
gonna send someone else that's why I'm
going like this is this is my mission
America sending me and these are the
values I hold dear I'm gonna go forth
and and go and so my I've kind of the
idea that now his kind of cross to bear
if you will sitting up talking to the
big guy upstairs is if not me then who
am i Tazewell be my name on the
organization to represent this sort of
veteran space and trying to get more of
us out there to raise awareness and and
to really empower the next generation as
well and so we're just so aligned that
it's such an easy rewarding partnership
for us yeah awesome no it's uh just so
awesome to have Ryan on this podcast and
and hear everything about the foundation
what they're doing I did like a video
that they present to schools for kids
you know talking about discipline and
integrity and leadership and so they're
just getting the word out there and I
appreciate that you guys are helped and
spread that word as well so that's
awesome well we're looking at a little
over three hours right now you you made
this really easy the website is go rock
comm exactly the Facebook the Twitter
the Instagram the YouTube channel it's
all at GORUCK and people can find you
people can participate in these thousand
events you got coming up what do they do
just go out where do you sign up so it's
also on on the website there's events
that are that are on there I mean
there's you know if you go to the site
you'll see a lot of gear and stuff as
well like that's that's the other part
of what we do it's kind of complicated
like that right it's really like a
fitness thing with backpacks though
right we manufacture gear you've got
this rucksack or this backpack you can
do a lot with it and so yeah there's a
lot of events and nobody wanted the name
GORUCK except for us and so all of our
social media stuff is go ruck oh yeah
except there was this Hungarian
photographer early on whose name was
like Gora Gora yeah
and so he had the Twitter handle and I
pestered him for forever and eventually
he cancelled his account and then that
triggered all these other things
eventually we claimed it
we're not hugely on the twitter space
but it's everything's go rock the house
that's awesome eckhart you got anything
yeah what what kind of dog is Jabba Java
is a so Java was a chocolate lab he
passed away in 2013 it was one of those
situations where I mean we had this
really big event we've done an obstacle
course race out in in a Virginia like a
confidence course I mean would trees
with nets and stuff and you know balance
walks and all this stuff and it was our
first venture into that as a way to get
people out there we ended up never doing
that again because it was just too
labor-intensive but Java got really sick
right before that and spent a lot of
time and I slept on the floor at the at
the the vet's office in Northern
Virginia for like two weeks became
really good friends with Heather who was
the veterinarian there's still a really
close personal friend of mine but he it
was basically diagnosis by exclusion
they it just got some autoimmune disease
like lupus and I just watched him wither
away to nothing
and so the that's the sad part of the
story it comes to all of us you just
have to kind of deal with it and and
then we got monster so if you go to our
site or you see pictures now most of
them are of monster he's also a an
English chocolate lab so he's got this
kind of blockhead and those two dogs
they look kind of similar but Monster is
literally the nicest dog ever I mean
Java was kind of had those fangs at the
ready and the great protector and
monster just he'll roll over on his back
with you know all four paws in the air
and just know no predator to that dog
exists whatsoever and you know life's a
funny place like that sometimes they're
they're both great they're just complete
opposite right all anything else echo
that's it good thanks so much for having
me guys and this has been fun yeah man
anything else any closing thoughts
we missed uh at least on this round you
tell me you got any big advice for me
I'm sure you've dug in to go rock and
you've seen sort of our stuff with a
fresh set of eyes you you do a lot of
business consulting you solve a lot of
problems you've seen a lot of leaders
along the way I mean what do you see of
what we're doing and what are we doing
well and look what could be be doing
better I think what you're doing well
and what I thought I'm glad that you
already figured out is like you're
focused on helping people out and you're
exposing them to I don't know if I want
to call it a form of exercise because
it's really a lot more than that you
know going out on a on a rock hump like
I said I've talked about it before it
had a big impact on my life it has a big
impact on the way I think about things
in general so I think the fact that
you're taking something that helped you
and is opening the doors to a lot of
people I don't think there's a better
business plan than that man so keep
getting after it is what I always say
all right we'll keep getting after it
same thing and yeah thanks for what
you're doing there thanks for helping
out the TMF the Travis Travis Manion
Foundation that's awesome
of course thanks for your service man
appreciate it likewise Jocko thanks what
you're doing all right brother we'll
talk to you later and with that Jason
has left the building
and while while Jason has left the
building I am going to be entering some
buildings around America speaking to
people yes going on tour
all right live gigs if you want to come
January 6 Washington DC January 11th
Austin already sold-out sorry
January 16th New York January 20th LA
January 27th and then January 27th in
Seattle in January 28th San Fran Cisco
so looking at the maps of the assorted
event venues they are one is sold out
like I said Austin the other ones are in
the process
of selling out so if you want to come
jump on there go to Jaco live.com and
get yourself some tickets to come hang
out I'm gonna talk EKKO is gonna be
there some of them I think that's what
we're planning yeah we're sorting that
out Wilson maybe all of them maybe some
of them not none of them for people that
like echo hopefully it's one of the ones
that you're going to for those people
that don't like echo there are people
out there like that
I believe so yes yeah if you don't like
echo well you're all right you can still
come and all right so we talked a lot
about rocking which we've talked about
before certainly a good way to make
yourself better not the only way there
are some other ways to make yourself
better there's ways to provide yourself
support while you're actually supporting
what we're doing here kind of this whole
thing you know it's true echo Charles
hey you don't know how rocking like you
know what I think about rocking is in
the airport to me when I think of
rocking and you I think you have no idea
what this is because my camera bag is
pretty heavy and then my computer bag
it's pretty heavy
it's heavier than a regular computer bag
well my computer is kind of heavy
because big even though only as 4
terabyte drive yes yeah weak anyway it's
still a heavy computer so I'm saying so
when you carry the camera bag and the
computer bag when you travel you walk
from terminal to terminal point here you
know to all these different gates this
is basically been through the Special
Forces course is it what I'm hearing
pretty much is what I'm saying
that's what I'm hearing and even I don't
know how a real ruck feels I don't
that's what I was thinking like you'd
have no idea what we're talking about I
have an idea we might as well be talking
about you know walking around on Mars in
low gravity or whatever gravity they
have on Mars yeah walk around on them
down with low gravity where you're like
this
I can imagine what it's like but I have
no idea I disagree because when I walk
around with that it's like a little like
workout so then when it comes right you
kind of know what to delist my mind like
where it's like hey this isn't really a
workout it's a workout but it's not the
workout extra special forces to coerce
Dominator via carry on carry on luggage
yes sir
and it's very true because I'm just
trying to get from point A to point B
are you gonna start a company called go
luggage where you go carry luggage
around an airport for a workout anyway
just wondering I know exactly what's
going on but it's exactly here look
let's say you know exactly what well
maybe not exactly but it's it's like you
know like that you could you could
isolate that as a work cuz like when
he's talking oh yes actually I do know
what's going on because when he
explained how it feels to take off like
the rucksack when you're done I was like
bro you're talking about me you're
talking about me you were you are a a
backpack yes sir for let's call it seven
minutes as you get through there and
then you finally get after that
treacherous journey you get to your
first class seat on the airplane you get
to unload that burden oh yeah you feel
my blood go back and then the girl comes
over and says would you like a champagne
no sir no man I'm too busy
basically right I think I think that's
the sfq course the same thing I think
that's Ranger school you just completed
anyway I'm doing jujitsu I don't know
what you change the subject well that's
all and sometimes I'll do it with a
rucksack on you do jujitsu the rucksack
on if you had a rucksack on did you do
too if you if the rucksack was like
streamlined I don't know like how but I
mean they get there's varying levels of
bulk right with you I mean this for the
levels right yeah but if you had a
streamlined rucksack mmm jujitsu might
it might benefit you because we reduced
the weight used to the weight sure but
no no as far as like performance goes
because you'd be heavier on them to go
like they couldn't really stay on your
back you seem sad room yeah it's kind of
unrealistic but nonetheless I do jujitsu
and you
an aware rucksack most of the time I
wear again some of the time half a day
where do you get your key from origin so
you go to origin mean calm baby what is
important about origin why well depends
on who you are but in my opinion what's
significant been significantly important
is that they're made in America okay
the maiden America sounds cool I
appreciate it but what if we want high
quality yes same deal
so I was gonna say the second most
significant thing is I mean America the
high quality that's the first most
significant thing that's all its gonna
say so orange and main calm get your
gear get your rash guards get your
t-shirts and by the way since we can't
walk around America wearing gay pants
you can get a pair of origin jeans same
deal America permit the materials
materials raw materials raw materials
yeah what the cotton whatever right you
were talking to somebody and you said it
like cotton to know you were really yeah
I don't know if you're imitating me I
was at 1% because otherwise they're
really strongly G but it wasn't cotton
it was button you said but that same
thing some but I'm just doing that to
imitate you whatever bread that's your
jam now so go ahead run with it I think
anyway jeans yes good jeans too not just
some rent like junk jeans they're good
turn them inside out like pizzas and
look at the quality on the inside these
aren't normal jeans these are the best
jeans in the world that's that's where
I'm gonna say agree actually and also we
have a lighter weight jeans that are out
right now
mmm-hmm at least they're close to being
out there called
forgot the 68 but I have them they're
not for me they've been out for a while
one pair out that no no they're in
production for sure that's 100 percent
so if you want to get a pair that's a
little lighter weight it's weird too
right because here I am mister
heavyweight hoodie sure but I like
lightweight jeans I guess
the way things are gonna shake out
sometimes the only times I've ever been
called you how many times I've ever been
in my life said ooh my legs are cold
I don't know zero never all right well
yeah I mean it kind of makes sense if
you look at it practically because if
you're gonna be in a situation where
like the weather and the temperature is
this thing you're not gonna be like yeah
let me get my heavyweight clothes but
not my my pants like it just doesn't
make sense like that seem sane so
anytime where it's like a temperature
dictated scenario you never really have
the opportunity to have your legs cold
seems saying mmm
like if you go to Monaco taking point
taken
yes gonna top so it's like cool that's
cool and everything but so I really
didn't say much you didn't say much
right well we got lightweight jeans
Delta 68 named after my forefathers and
the SEAL Teams who wore jeans in the
Mekong Delta and Nam also supplements
and by the way and which I dig I dig
that you know the jeans but until they
come out you know I can't get too
emotionally moved and buy it unless
supplements I can because these
supplements are as it turns out the most
important supplements that that there
are for your joints joint warfare and
super krill oil cold war by the way
which is really put it in work recently
my son is sick so you know I'm using
this a lot the cold war to prevent and
head off any sicknesses that might be
coming your way
immunity supplement yeah also monk
additional protein in the form of a
dessert just stick with Don ready to
drink discipline go in a can tropic
thunder citrus we got that's kind of
mine my go-to is psycho citrus it's sort
of like a lemon lime Tropic Thunder is
kind of like a a pineapple coconut and
then of course we have dak savage is
that your personal favorite
by a little bit but yes so there's not a
huge margin of favoritest close close
close
did you see Dakota posted on his
Instagram account which I know you refer
to that as the grand but he posted like
he just got I don't know like an entire
pallet of Jack savage to his house good
move kotas not playing around no well
yeah yeah first and then close second is
chocolate I don't forget about jock or
white tea if you need to improve your
deadlift I mean yeah it tastes good yeah
it's certified organic yeah it's got a
little caffeine yeah it's got any
oxidants in it all that's cool it's good
but let's face it you're getting that
for that 8000 pound deadlift gear all
and strawberry and chocolate warrior kid
milk Oh what if you came home and you're
like oh well what do you want to give
your kid to eat right now how about
poison no no no please no one says that
and yet they give their kids sugar
filled desserts treats snacks Funyuns
whatever those are I kind of do but I
don't think I liked them for all yeah
they were kind of that was like a
love-hate scenario for sure yeah well
anyways don't give your kids any of that
stuff when they want something tasty
give him some warrior Kid Mork also
Chuck was a store it's called jaw closed
or jaw closed or calm JP Danelle shout
out by the way
he was well you know doing his workout
apparently he posted a picture of post
work I posted a picture post worked out
mm-hmm picture wearing one of the many
shirts oh the new you the new deaf shirt
there was the new death shirt and there
was also a little lightweight hoodie
scenario so he's just getting after he's
getting out and representing Iowa is he
on the path he's on the path so he's
representing while he's on the path but
someone did ask hey where do you get
that so I you know we said every week
sure I'm sitting in chaco store
Jaakko store calm so we can get the
stuff to represent while you're on the
path
t-shirts - - guards truckers hats like
fit if that's your thing
be nice be nice Odie's lightweight and
heavy hmm check depends on what you mean
by heavy anyway a lot of cool stuff I'm
on there check it out if you like
something get something there's women's
stuff on there too and for the warrior
kids oh yeah everything yeah
that's Christmas time how stoked are you
and your little kid opens about warrior
kid package and it's a t-shirt for your
kids walking around school representing
how your kids on the path representing
oh yeah or she's in the path oh yeah so
yeah all that stuff chuckles door
dot-com also you wanna subscribe to the
potty or so should I say if you want to
subscribe to the podcast go ahead do so
I'm not like I'm not gonna sit here you
don't think that someone's on podcast
208 and there's for the hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of hours of us
talking and you think they didn't get to
the end and like hit subscribe yeah I
don't know but it's possible or it's
possible that maybe someone just had
stumbled upon podcasts in general is
that possible i sat next to a woman on
the plane sure and and she was older
than me and she asked me something and
somehow she asked what I was doing
because I was like preparing something
sure and I said all I'm writing this for
for a podcast and she goes oh and I said
do you know what podcasts are she didn't
like that I said that did she say of
course she goes which she goes of course
I know what a podcast is she said I'm
not that old and I said I know you're
not I said but a lot of people don't
know and by the way I said I'm probably
older than you and she said there's a
zero chance that you're older than me
uh-huh but were you know no I was not or
you're scared to ask her uh actually she
told me her age and she's older than me
she was older than me well there you go
but here's the thing you really didn't
gain much information because it's not
like you had you said do you know what
podcasts are you can ask her do you know
whether or not to subscribe do you know
that it's possible to subscribe so yes
you know what I didn't I took her phone
and I showed her darker podcast okay I
press subscribe for her and she was
already in kind of in the game yeah yeah
she was interested in what was happening
yeah man now she's in the game fully
there and either way whether she knew to
subscribe or not she's subscribed but
the question still remains does everyone
know about podcasts and the subscription
option if you don't know to subscribe
then subscribe and also you may not have
been aware because this was probably the
worst launch in the history of launches
randomly maybe a echos big effort to
make a impact in the world we have
another podcast which is called a
grounded and we talk about casual things
of life including jiu-jitsu and not so
casual things but it's a little bit not
a quite as heavy or structured or yeah
as this podcast it's called the grounded
podcast you can subscribe to that one
too you can also subscribe to war your
kid podcast there's give me some new
ones coming out you know the worst was
when that kid sent me a letter that said
I'm wondering why you don't make more
podcasts yeah and don't forget about
warrior kids soap go to Irish Oaks
ranch calm Eden is up there making soap
but we got a new soap coming out by the
way damn what's gonna be able to you
soon you don't know what it's called yes
sir I do
it's called killer so called killer so
is it antibacterial or antibacterial and
I'm actor microbe R'lyeh tea tree oil
see that's good so it's gonna be coming
out through check out the killer soap
does this make me a marketing genius as
the question I know well you're kind of
looking like it was a marketing genius
it's a good product we'll say that you
conveyed that message very clearly and
so yeah I guess so genius well what
would you have called it I something
lame is what I'm feeling we have a
youtube channel how about that that's
marketing guess what YouTube channel
videos the thing nowadays right
marketing de right video
it's it's a good addition for instance
if someone's listening to this podcast
and they want to see what Jason looks
like they can go on there and they can
see what Jason looks like they can also
see what I look like and in fact they
can see what you look like
sure which most people don't think you
look like what you sound like that's the
consensus yeah don't don't be worried
about it bro I'm not we're all good
wait what would you prefer to have the
current scenario which is you sound
small weak and frail but you're actually
kind of jacked we did rather sound like
the Zuko Charles but then you were
skinny and weak yeah besides your knees
well I think the answer is obvious or
would I rather look how it cuz this is
the knock on how I sound really so
technically the dichotomy or the other
side of the dichotomy it would be like
would I rather sound yeah yeah what I
rather sound big and look small or look
big and sound small mmm that's kind of
what would your auditors you're good
with way very good you know yeah YouTube
yeah and an echo makes like videos not
just of this podcast but also enhanced
videos and Mikey and the Dragons which
is a children's book that I wrote that
John Bozak did the artwork for we we
just posted the entire thing cover to
cover on YouTube so that kids around the
world can watch and learn how to
overcome fear yeah my kids love that
video by the way yeah listen watching it
even since before we both yes
psychological warfare got a little album
out and it has tracks and if you have a
little moment where you're like man I
wish soccer would just kind of like give
me a little give me a little talk right
now get me in the game
that's what it is you think you're gonna
not you think you're not gonna workout
you think you're gonna lay in bed you
think you're gonna grab all that don't
not know I'm gonna stop you just press
play on your
your listening device and listen that
mp3 you can get that on the mp3 dealer
iTunes Google Play stitcher whatever
leave reviews actually it's not stitcher
it's iTunes Google Play whatever mp3
platforms don't forget about flipside
canvas maybe you need a visual kind of a
visual reinforcement of the path cool go
to flipside canvas comm which is run by
my brother Dakota Meyer and you can get
yourself some some graphic
representation of what we call the path
yes sir it will remind you and it will
keep you on it got some books got
leadership strategy and tactics Field
Manual pre-order it now so that the
publisher knows how many to print
because otherwise they're over there
round and down right they're like well
we probably will get away with this no
they don't understand let him understand
pre-order it get one for you get one for
your your significant other get one get
one for each of the people on your team
get one for your pockets just get some
leadership strategy and tactics Field
Manual all the little questions that we
have about leadership are in here
indexed heavily so you can look through
the index making an ultimatum as the
boss hmm making an ultimatum as a
subordinate okay
that those are interesting right dealing
with an ultimatum placed on you that's
these are these are important things to
know and understand balancing praise
that sounds like a good idea
tactfully delivering the truth I'm just
looking to giving clear guidance keeping
the troops informed so these are all
punishment how did how to mete out
punishment you like that you made that
little video of this yes wait for the
book yeah of me saying when do I punish
people so that's good leadership
strategy tactics
check it out way the warrior kids series
one two and three all available all the
books that you would have wanted when
you were a kid if I would have had these
books when I was a kid my life would
have been better and that's a bold
statement so way the warrior kid way the
warrior kid to Mark's mission and way
the warrior kid three where there's a
will get your kid on the path look I
know you want them on the path but it's
hard when you're a parent because your
kids don't really want to listen to you
they don't don't listen to Uncle Jake
though for some reason that listen to
Uncle Jake so get them those books and
then Mikey and the dragons look cool
watch the video cool we put it on
YouTube for free obviously but what you
can do is you get your kids the book and
then they can read along and they learn
to read they learn to read while they
learn to overcome fear
you're welcome Merry Christmas
then there's discipline equals freedom
Field Manual there's the holiday gift
give the gift of discipline discipline
equals freedom Field Manual the audio
versions are on mp3 platforms then
extreme ownership and the dichotomy a
leadership that I wrote with my brother
Leif babban
leadership is the most important thing
on the battlefield these books will show
you the principles that we used on the
battlefield that you can use in your
business and life national on front
leadership consultancy we solve problems
through leadership go to echelon front
comm for details
EF online you know I used to be able to
say to people well you know got some
good leadership lessons gold oh you got
some questions about extreme ownership
oh you got some oh cool here
go to you know go listen to my podcast
it's like okay cool what does that look
like now I say go listen to the podcast
and what does that turn into that turns
into 700 hours of training for your
people not always the most efficient way
it's a good what whatever doctorate
level but let's get this thing concise
that's what EF all - EF on line is boom
here you go here's some pragmatic
training information for you and your
team you can get on there you're going
to be put in leadership situations where
you have to make decisions it's
interactive it's entertaining
you get to see the Echelon front team
putting out the word so check out EF
online.com and then muster 2020 dates
are coming we're actually finalizing
those right now if you want to come to a
leadership event slash seminar slash
conference with me and the rest of the
ashkelon front team go to extreme
ownership calm so you're aware when the
details come out and then of course now
we have EF overwatch and EF legion we
are placing military members that have
leadership skills and experience and
that understand the principles that we
teach and we are placing those military
personnel into civilian businesses to
lead those businesses so that they can
dominate their battle space so go to EF
overwatch comm or EF Legion comm and if
you want to follow follow up with us if
you've got questions or answers or
comments or whatever if you want to
connect if you want to be part of the
community no we're not saying that if
you want to connect with us well Jason
and GORUCK all channels at GORUCK and
then we are also on the interwebs on
Twitter on Instagram and on this friggin
bezel echo is at Echo Charles and I am
at Jocko will Inc and once again thanks
to Jason McCarthy for coming on the
podcast and sharing his experience and
of course thanks to Jason for his
service in the army and for what he is
doing now and thanks to all the men and
women out there that have served and
that are currently serving going through
the long nights the early mornings the
cold the heat the risk of life and limb
all to protect freedom and democracy
thanks to all of you and to those brave
individuals doing that same thing here
in America to keep us safe at home our
police and law enforcement firefighters
paramedics and EMTs dispatchers
correctional officers board
trol Secret Service and all force first
responders thank you for what you do and
on top of those two I want to also give
credit to our intelligence community out
there in America and overseas doing work
to keep us safe taking the fight to the
enemy
by knowing and understanding who they
are and what they do and to everyone
else out there things aren't always
going to go the way that you think they
will there will be challenges and there
will be obstacles and there will be
unexpected problems and you will
sometimes have to carry more weight than
you want to you might have to carry more
weight than you think you can and when
that happens remember to take that
weight take it on your shoulders stand
up put one foot in front of the other
and keep getting after it and until next
time this is echo and Jocko out